OKAY HERE WE GO. THE SENATE
BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE WILL COME TO
ORDER GOOD AFTERNOON AS WE
CONTINUE TO TAKE SOME
PRECAUTIONS TO MANAGE ONGOING
COVER NINETEEN RISKS THE SENATE
CONTINUES TO WELCOME THE PUBLIC
AND HAS PROVIDED ACCESS TO BOTH
IN PERSON AND TELECONFERENCE
BECAUSE THE PATIENT FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT FOR INDIVIDUALS WISHING
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT VIA
THE TELECONFERENCE IS THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER AND
ACCESS CODE IS. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN TWO TWO SIX EIGHT ONE SIX
THREE THAT'S THE TOLL FREE
NUMBER AND THE ACCESS CODE IS.
SEVEN THREE SIX TWO EIGHT THREE
THREE. E WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM
DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY WE DON'T EXPECT BUT IF
AN INDIVIDUAL IS DISRUPTIVE-
HERE SHE MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE
REMOTE MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE
THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED WE AE
HOLDING OUR HEARINGS ARE
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE-
STREET BUILDING IN ROOM TWENTY
ONE HUNDRED- OF THOSE PROVIDING
TESTIMONY BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
TODAY. ARE ALSO PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY FOR OUR REMOTE
PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE YOUR
PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS WILL
GREATLY AID AND THE LEMONADE AND
THE ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK I ASK THAT
EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED THAT YOU USE THE-
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM. EACH TIME WE ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF
YOU'D LIKE TO UNMUTE. PLEASE
SELECT A NEW BEFORE YOU BEGIN
SPEAKING OUR IT PERSONNEL VERY
VERY COMPETENT IT PERSONNEL WILL
PUT YOU BACK ON MUTE WHEN YOU
ARE DONE ONCE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK PLEASE MAKE SURE YOU CAN
BE SEEN ON THE SCREEN STATE YOUR
NAME. AND THEN YOU'RE READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE TO ALLOW
THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
IN THE HEARING ROOM. OUGHT TO
THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
AND WE WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE OF HIS FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. PUBLIC COMMENT WILL BE
HEARD AFTER ALL DISCUSSION ITEMS
HAVE BEEN PRESENTED. BEFORE WE
BEGIN OF PLEASE LET'S STOP WAS A
QUORUM MR HACKER. THE RAZA HERE
FOR CASEY YOUR GROWTH NEWMAN
HERE. OF A QUORUM YES OKAY SO A
CONSULTANT OF THE CORN HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED WE WILL BE
DISCUSSING ALL THE ISSUES IN THE
DISCUSSION SECTION OF THE
AGENDA- AND THEN WE WILL TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT AND THEN WE WILL
VOTE ON THE- VOTE ONLY ITEMS SO
TODAY WE BEGIN OUR DISCUSSION
AND PRESENTATIONS WITH ISSUE
SEVENTEEN. THIS IS THE
TRANSPORTATION AND FREIGHT
INFRASTRUCTURE PACKAGE THIS ITEM
WILL BE PRESENTED BY THE L. A.
O. FOLLOWED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION. BUT AND OR
FINANCE. SOLD WHAT WE HAVE HERE
FOR A. THE L. A. O. WHO IS
PRESENTING HERE. L. B. IN THIS
ROW FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. TWEET
COMMITTEE SORRY LET ME JUST FIND
THIS.
OKAY. OKAY GO AHEAD THANK YOU.
NO WORRIES THANK YOU CHAIR HI
EUNICE RODE THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AND SAID AS WE
HAVE BEEN ASKED BY COMMITTEE
STAFF TO PRESENT THE SENATE
MAJORITIES TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE PACKAGE- AND WE
WANT TO CLARIFY THAT THIS. AND
L. A. O. AND DORIS MET OF THE
PROPOSED PACKAGE IN ANY SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS REGARDING THE PACKAGE
SHOULD BE DIRECTED EITHER TO THE
CHAIR THE COMMITTEE STAFF. AND
SO AS PART OF OUR PRESENTATION
WILL FIRST ADD BRIEFLY
SUMMARIZED THAT GOVERNORS-
PROPOSED AS TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE PACKAGE THAT WAS
INTRODUCED IN JANUARY'S BUDGET
AND HURT BY THIS COMMITTEE IN
FEBRUARY- AND THEN GIVE A HIGH
LEVEL OVERVIEW OF THE SENATE
MAJORITIES PROPOSED PACKAGE- AS
HIGHLIGHTED ON A PAGE THIRTEEN
OF YOUR AGENDA- IN TOTAL THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET
INCLUDED SIX POINT TWO BILLION
FOR VARIOUS TYPES OF
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE.
THIS INCLUDED FIVE BILLION FROM
THE GENERAL FUND OVER THREE
YEARS FOR A PACKAGE OF PROPOSALS
TO SUPPORT AND AREAS THAT
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS SUCH AS TRANSIT AND
RAIL GRADE SEPARATION ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION CLIMATE
ADAPTATION HIGHLY CONVERSION
AND- SCREENING UPSTATE HIGHWAYS
. AND IN ADDITION TO THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO INCLUDES
ONE POINT TWO BILLION FROM THE
GENERAL FUND OVER TWO YEARS FOR
UP COURTS AND GOODS MOVEMENT FOR
STRUCTURE AS PART OF THEIR-
BROADER SUPPLY CHAIN RESILIENCE
PACKAGE. SENATE MAJORITY-
PROPOSES A TRANSPORTATION AND
FREIGHT INFRASTRUCTURE PACKAGE
FUNDED AT TWENTY BILLION FROM
THE GENERAL FUND OVER FOUR
YEARS- THIS IS SUMMARIZED ON
PAGE FIFTEEN OF YOUR AGENDA. AND
IN TOTAL AND THE PACKAGE
INCLUDES THIRTEEN POINT EIGHT
BILLION OVER FOUR YEARS FOR
TRANSFER AND TRANSIT
INFRASTRUCTURE- TO BE
DISTRIBUTED THROUGH BOTH
COMPETITIVE AND FORMULA BASED
PROGRAMS. NINE BILLION OVER FOUR
YEARS FOR A CRIME INVESTMENTS
INCLUDING ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS- AS WELL AS LOCAL AND
STATE CRIME ADAPTATION PLANNING
AND THAT PROJECT IMPLEMENTATION.
TWO POINT ONE BILLION OVER FOUR
YEARS FOR FREIGHT AND WORKFORCE
INVESTMENT SUGGEST POOR
INFRASTRUCTURE WORKFORCE
TRAINING CENTER AND OTHER GOODS
MOVEMENT PROJECTS. AND ONE POINT
TWO FIVE BILLION OVER FOUR YEARS
FOR CONGESTION MITIGATION AND
BRIDGE REPAIR AND REPLACEMENT.
THAT THE SENATE MAJORITIES
OPPOSE PACKAGE DIFFERS FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL AND A
FEW WAYS- INCLUDING WINE AN
INCREASE IN OVERALL FUNDING AN
AMOUNT. AND THE TO THE ADDITION
OF A FORMULA BASED FUNDING FOR
TRANSIT INFRASTRUCTURE OUR AS
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IS- ALL
COMPETITIVE AND THREE EXCLUSION
OF FUNDING FOR A CLEAN
CALIFORNIA FOR- BURKE EXCLUSION
ADDITIONAL FUNDING SORRY AND
THEN FOR OF REPLACING- STATE
FUNDS WITH FEDERAL FUNDS FOR
STATE CRIME ADAPTATION
ACTIVITIES. IN FIVE EDITION OF-
LABOR REQUIREMENTS. SO THAT
CONCLUDES OUR PRESENTATION ON
THAT SENATE MAJORITY SAD.
PROPOSED TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE PACKAGE- AS I
NOTED EARLIER ASSETS THIS IS NOT
AN ALLEY- PACKAGE ANY SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS REGARDING PACKAGE
SHOULD BE DIRECTED EITHER TO
CHAIRED COMMITTEE STAFF BUT WE
ARE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY OVER
ARCHING. TRANSPORTATION FUNDING
QUESTIONS- KIDS AGREED THAT WE
CAN BE AND HOW HELPFUL AS YOU
CONSIDER YOUR OPTIONS THANK YOU
. THANK YOU MISS WROTE- WE WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO. ON THE
MINISTRATION OR THE- FINANCE.
YES GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR-
CHARLES ONE. DEPUTY SECRETARY
BUDGET MINISTRATION
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
THE SUBCOMMITTEE. INSTRUCTION IS
NOT HAVE A POSITION ON SENATE
TRANSPORTATION PROPOSAL THIS
TIME HOWEVER I WOULD LIKE TO
TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
RESTATEMENTS RATIONS POSITION ON
ANY POTENTIAL TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE PACKAGE.
ADMINISTRATION'S POSITION
CONTINUES TO BE THAT ANY FUNDING
INCLUDED FOR THE TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE WILL BE
CONTINGENT UPON RECEIVING AN
APPROPRIATION FOR THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL WHICH IS NOTABLY NOT
INCLUDED IN THE SENATE'S
PROPOSAL WE DO LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU AND YOUR STAFF
ON THIS PARTICULAR PACKAGE FOR
THE STATE'S INFRASTRUCTURE
PACKAGE. THANK YOU. OKAY. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR QUAN- NOW
WILL HAVE SOME COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS FROM OUR OUR COMMITTEE
. ANYONE SENATOR NEWMAN OR
SENATORS WHO WOULD YOU LIKE TO
GO FIRST I'M JUST A STORY I DO
APPRECIATE THE ADMINISTRATION
POSITIONS RELATES TO FUNNY RICE
THE ROUTE I HOPE IT'S A TOPIC
THAT WE CAN. DISCUSS IN ARRIVE
AT BETTER REASONABLE POSITION IN
PLAN FOR- CALIFORNIA THAT. GREAT
I'M ALL JUST A FEW MINUTES A FEW
THINGS HERE- I REALLY- BELIEVE
VERY STRONGLY THAT
TRANSPORTATION HAS TO BE A
PRIORITY THIS YEAR NOT TO SAY IT
HASN'T BEEN IMPORTANT IN THE
PAST- TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE HAVE A COME
TO US. EACH EXPRESSING ENORMOUS
NEED OUT IN THE FIELD OF
TRANSPORTATION ONE ONE FACET OR
ANOTHER- AND I TRULY BELIEVE
THAT NOW'S THE TIME TO MAKE
THOSE INVESTMENTS WE HAVE THE
FUNDING- FOR FROM THE STATE. OF
THERE'S IDEAL JOB CREATING
OPPORTUNITIES AND THE MORE MONEY
WE PUT IN THE MORE WE CAN GET
POTENTIALLY FROM FEDERAL FUNDS
OF SO I THINK GETTING HAVING THE
LEVERAGE OF FEDERAL FUNDS OUGHT
TO FINISHED PRODUCTS THERE ARE
PROJECTS THAT ARE- THAT ARE OUT
THERE AND THAT. ALL IMPORTANT
AGAIN EVERYWHERE FROM THE INLAND
EMPIRE TO BAY AREA- SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA ORANGE COUNTY- A
NUMBER OF- OF AGENCIES HAVE COME
TO US WITH THEIR REQUEST OF. THE
OTHER PART OF THIS- I THINK
PROPOSAL- FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDING
TO BE SPENT IS THAT CONSTRUCTION
JOBS WILL BE HIGH QUALITY WAGES
AND BENEFITS WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
THE LABOR STANDARDS IN THERE
THAT MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S THE
INVESTMENT ON THE BUSINESS SIDE
BUT ACTUALLY INVESTMENT. ON THE
OFF WORKING FAMILIES SITE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE GOOD WITH
BENEFITS AND- WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE WHILE WE HAVE FAR MORE
EXPERIENCE ALL WITH THE
CONSTRUCTION SIDE WITH PLA'S AND
COMMUNITY WORKFORCE AGREEMENTS
WE NEED TO ALSO- MOVE THAT INTO
OUR OTHER. INVESTMENTS AND WE
NEED ENFORCEABLE- COMMITMENTS A
TO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S NOT A
TRICKLE DOWN BUT IT'S ACTUALLY
GOING TO BE PATHWAYS TO GOOD
PAYING IN DEMAND JOBS- AND
THAT'S WHAT OF- SENATE
TRANSPORTATION PACKAGE- INCLUDES
AS WELL. SO WITH THAT- I DON'T
KNOW SENATE QUARTERS IF YOU HAD
SOME OTHER COMMENTS PLEASE. YES
IN IN THE PRIOR. HEARING I
REALLY I MADE COMMENTS SAID I
WOULD PROBABLY JUST MAKE IT
AGAIN TODAY BUT- I'LL TRY TO
SORT OF MINIMIZE THE COMMENTARY
A COUPLE QUESTIONS ONE- IN THE.
THE DISTRIBUTION ON THE ON THE
CHART IN THE OF THE PACKAGE OF
THE BREAKDOWN I GUESS WHICH CALL
IT- THE ONE POINT TWO FIVE
BILLION FOR SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
TRANSIT PROJECTS HOW IS SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA BEING DEFINED- IN
TERMS OF JURISDICTIONS INCLUDED
. WHO WILL LOVE THIS IF THAT'S
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA YOU KNOW I
KNOW IT'S NOT THE LAYMAN'S
VERSION OF ANYTHING SOUTH OF-
THE GRAPEVINE BUT YOU KNOW I
GUESS I'M I JUST REALLY WANTING
FROM A JURISDICTIONAL STANDPOINT
BECAUSE WE HAVE SOME PRETTY BIG
COUNTIES IN ENTITIES DOWN THERE
. SOME ARE WHICH WHICH- THE SEBI
ON PARTS TO THIS WOULD BE ON THE
CHART I'M LOOKING AT THE CHART
IN. ALL THE ADMINISTRATION OKAY
THAT'S WHAT I DID WRONG MRS
MINISTRATION OF THE SENATE SIDE.
RATED MINISTRATION PROPOSAL OKAY
SO WAIT WOULD YOU RATHER ME WAIT
- TO GO OVER THERE. I'M FINE-
YEAH BUT I'M I'M JUST HAVE A
QUESTION ABOUT THIS REALLY ISSUE
SEVENTEEN THAT I'M PICKING THE
CHARTER YES YES IT'S ISSUE
SEVENTEEN AND THE CHART IN
YOU'RE REFERRING TO THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL RIGHT
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED OKAY SO THAT
MEANS- MISTER QUANT. YES THANK
YOU. SO WE ARE PROPOSAL WOULD
REALLY IN RESPONSE TO PREVIOUS-
COMMENTS AND BEEN MADE ABOUT-
NECESSARILY FIND NECESSARY
FUNDING FOR SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
TRANSIT PROJECTS I DON'T KNOW
THAT WE HAVE THAT SPECIFICALLY
DEFINES- ANYWHERE IN STATUTE OR
ANYTHING BUT- WE WOULD BE HAPPY
TO WORK WITH YOUR STAFF TO
DEFINE- BUT THE DEFINITION OF
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. WE
APPRECIATE THAT I THINK YOU KNOW
WE ARE AND ALSO WE- YOU KNOW
BECAUSE THE WAY WERE ORGANIZED
IN THE SENATE COMING BACK TO THE
SENATE SIDE OF THINGS WE YOU
KNOW A LOT OF THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE. PACKAGE IF YOU
WILL HAS BEEN- LOOKED UP BY
CAUCUS UNITED BAY AREA CAUCUSES
GOT ITS LANDS INLAND EMPIRE'S
GOT ITS LANDS SACRAMENTO'S GOT
ITS LANDS AND IT'S ALL IT'S ALL
BEEN TALKED ABOUT ALREADY. BUT
BUT IT JUST SEEMS LIKE WE'RE
CARING FOR THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. NOMENCLATURE ON THAT
PIECE OF ON THAT LEADS IN AND
THEY JUST. YOU KNOW ALTHOUGH I
SEE IN MY OWN NOTES ON THE
SENATE PACKAGE YOU KNOW AND I
DON'T KNOW. IF THIS IS
CONSISTENT WITH THE PRESENTATION
TODAY BUT HAVING SAN DIEGO KIND
OF BROKEN OUT SEPARATELY THESE
ARE MY NOTES HERE- I SHOW I SHOW
SAN DIEGO WITH A NUMBER.
SEPARATE APART OVER AND ABOVE
WHAT WOULD BE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA BUT THERE'S NO IF YOU
COME BACK TO. THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PACKAGE THERE
IS NO SAN DIEGO NUMBER SERVICE
I'M JUST TRYING TO MAKE SURE
WERE. WE'RE APPLES TO APPLES- OR
I AM AT LEAST IN TERMS OF MY OWN
UNDERSTANDING OF. WHERE WE WERE
OR WHERE WHERE MAYBE WE WERE AS
A STARTING POINT WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION'S- PACKAGE A
RECOMMENDATION AND THEN. HOW
THAT TRANSLATES OVER WITHOUT-
YOU KNOW ACTON ME WORRIED ABOUT
US CONFLATING. OR OR PACKAGING
AND THINGS TOGETHER THAT I
SHOULD BE DOING- SO THAT THAT'S
THE QUESTION AND. I HEARD THE
ANSWER TO IT IS. IT SOUNDED KIND
OF LIKE WE DON'T KNOW- BUT I
GUESS FOR ALL OF US I JUST FEEL
LIKE IT WOULD BE IMPORTANT GET
CLARITY ON THAT SOONER RATHER
THAN LATER ANGRY- ANGRY LASTLY
IN THE MINISTRATIONS. PACKAGE
THAT'S WERE I'M SORRY THIS IN
THE SENATE PACKAGE IS IT WHAT
IS. ME SINCE THAT'S ON THE TABLE
RIGHT NOW WITH. WHAT IS THE-
CONCEPT BASICALLY BY THE
PRESENTERS IN TERMS OF- HOW THAT
MONEY IS DISTRIBUTED- WE FOCUSED
IN EARLY ON AND IF YOU WERE TO
GO BACK AND PLAY BACK THE TAPE
OF MY COMMENTS FOR THE LAST YEAR
IN ON T. R. C. P. PER DECISION
AND THE FACT THAT I'M I WAS JUST
SAYING AT THE TIME IT SEEMED
LIKE THAT DOLLAR AMOUNT WAS TOO
LOW RELATIVE TO STATEWIDE NEED
IN THE WINDOW OF OPPORTUNITY
AND- I STAND BY ALL THOSE
COMMENTS. YOU KNOW I'M GLAD THAT
WERE. STARTING TO DEAL WITH SOME
LARGER NUMBERS HERE- YOU KNOW
AVAILABLE BECAUSE OF THE BENEFIT
OF THE SIZE OF THE STATE BUDGET-
BUT THAT SAID- I'M I'M STILL NOT
CLEAR ON. FORMULA VERSUS-
IDENTIFYING PROJECTS YOU KNOW
WE'VE BEEN LOOKING AT THIS IN MY
OFFICE AS YOU DON'T WANT TO MISS
THE OPPORTUNITY TO DEAL WITH
LEGACY PROJECTS BUT AT THE SAME
TIME OBVIOUSLY THERE SEEMED
THERE WOULDN'T BE TYPICALLY NEED
TO BE MONEY. DISTRIBUTED THROUGH
THE EMPTY OWES OR THROUGH THE
FORMULAS LIKE T. I. R. C. P. AS
WELL- IMAGES WERE AND HOW MUCH
THAT'S BEEN REFINED AT THIS
POINT. IN A NOTE THE PRESENTERS
CAN RESPOND TO THAT. OR WHO
WOULD BE APPROPRIATE TO RESPOND
TO IT. HE.
I THINK SIMILAR AT AND YOU CAN
SEE I THINK IN THE IN THE IN THE
SUMMARY OF THE SENATE'S OF- SOME
DESCRIPTION HERE OF WHAT OUR
PROPOSAL IS ONE I THINK WE WERE
FOCUSED ON FIRST AND FOREMOST
PUTTING MRE MONEY INTO THE
TRANSPORTATION BUDGET AND- AND
MAKING SURE THAT WE TAKE
ADVANTAGE LIKE I SAID OF A
FEDERAL FUNDING IN THE
LEVERAGING OF FEDERAL DOLLARS SO
THAT WAS I THINK THE FIRST THING
WE WANTED TO ACCOMPLISH OF.
WAITING GET INTO PARTICULAR
GEOGRAPHICAL AREAS- BUT I THINK
THAT- ANY ALL THESE. QUESTIONS
THAT YOU'RE ASKING WE SHOULD.
ADDRESS THEM I DON'T KNOW THAT
WE HAVE THE SPECIFIC RESPONSE TO
EACH ONE HERE BUT I THINK
THEY'RE COMPLETELY VALID VERY
IMPORTANT QUESTIONS THAT WE DO
NEED TO ANSWER. SO MAYBE CENTER
CRITICIZE YOU COULD YOU KNOW
GIVE US ALL YOUR QUESTIONS IF
YOU WANT RIGHT NOW WELL IN THAT
WAY THAT WAY WE WILL HAVE A MEN
WE'LL HAVE OUR- CONSULTANT- GET
BACK TO ALL OF US. AS TO WHERE
AND HOW WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
THOSE THOSE ISSUES A LONG RIGHT
ARM IN MAYBE IT DIDN'T AND IN
THAT THAT'S GREAT CONTACTS AND
IT'S VERY HELPFUL ITHINK THEN I
WOULD JUST SORT OF SUMMARIZE MY
QUESTIONS IN IN MORE OF A
GENERAL WAY AND SAY. THAT IT
SEEMS CLEAR TO ME AND IN THE
ANALYSIS WOULD GO TO MY OWN
OFFICE SAID THESE. THAT THOSE
THE QUESTIONS I STARTED TO ASK
OR ACTUALLY INTERTWINED OR SO.
CAN I- ARE IMPACTED BY ONE
ANOTHER THAT YOU KNOW. AGAIN I
THINK WE DO NEED TO CLEAR THOSE
UP I'M CERTAINLY- HELLO WE'VE
BEEN INVOLVED WE'VE BEEN ENGAGED
IN THE CONVERSATION OF MY
CHEAPEST OF HOUSES WELL SO. SO
MAYBE MORE THAN ANYTHING I'M
KIND OF PUTTING OUT HERE ON THE
RECORD WHAT I THINK ARE SOME OF
THE CONCERNS THAT WE- WOULD LIKE
TO KEEP WORKING ON TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE CLEAR ON IF WE DON'T. IF
WE DON'T HAVE- WE ARE CLEAR ON
THE GEOGRAPHIC AREAS THAT- ARE
GOING TO GET- SPECIFIC
ALLOCATIONS AT SOME POINT IF
THEY ARE- BUT- YOU KNOW. THAT
THAT COULD HAVE- SORT OF THE
BALANCE OF THE DOLLARS IMPACT ON
ON ANYTHING DISTRIBUTED BY
FORMULA FOR EXAMPLE RIGHT- SO
ANYWAY WE'RE WE'RE VERY
INTERESTED IN CONTINUING TO GET
TO THAT KIND OF DETAIL- IN.
BEGIN YOU KNOW IF THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA QUESTION IS JUST SORT
OF THE- THE JUMPING OUT THERE IS
. YOU KNOW ONE ONE WAY TO START
ARTICULATING- YOU KNOW THAT
QUESTION IF WE IF WE DON'T HAVE
THAT FIGURED OUT THEN THE WHAT
HAPPENS- TWO TWO DOLLARS IN THE
PACKAGE THAT OR- YOU KNOW.
REMAINING ON THAT WOULD BE
DISTRIBUTED ELSEWHERE SO THAT'S
ALL THAT'S ONLY HELP ON THAT A
MANAGER IN WILL THAT YOU BRING
ALONG WITH THE AGENDA. GREAT
THANK YOU FOR LINKING TO THANK
YOU AND IF YOU HAVE ADDITIONAL.
QUESTIONS OFTEN MAKE SURE OF YET
NO NO MAKE SURE WE GET THEM
EITHER HERE OR- IN NOT IN
WRITING TO A CONSULTANT AND I
JUST I WONDER I OPENED SO IT'S
PART OF THE ITEMS FOR DISCUSSION
. SERVICE BUT IT WILL RUN
SEVENTEEN RIGHT NOW UNDERSTOOD
UNDERSTOOD SO AS A WITNESS WE
HAVE. A OF THE ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING MONIES
AND SO YOU WE HAVE A LARGE
AMOUNT THAT WE'VE- PROSPECTIVELY
ALLOCATED TO INCREASE THE
GOVERNOR SURE THINKING THE UP TO
TWO BILLION DOLLARS FOR THE A.
T. P. PROGRAM- WHO- AND- THERE
ARE AS I UNDERSTAND IT THERE TOO
SERIOUS BUT ONE WOULD BE- TO DO
A NEW ROUND. OF PROPOSALS- YOUR
STORY STRAIGHT FROM SCRATCH THE
OTHER WHICH I. I WOULD FAVOR
CONSIDERING THE WORK THAT WENT
INTO LAST YEAR- IT WOULD BE TO
EXTEND THE- THE- AWARDS DOWN. TO
PROJECT THAT IT SCORED THAT IT
MISSED OUT BECAUSE OF THEIR
SCORE IN LAST TIME AND THE ON
THE ONE HAND THAT WOULD. SAVE A
BUNCH OF STAFF TIME- I THINK I
THINK THEY WERE THERE WERE A
NUMBER. OF RELIEF- YOU KNOW
VALID PROPOSALS I GREW
PRINCIPLES THAT DIDN'T MAKE THE
CUT OFF LAST TIME- AND SO IF AND
WHEN WE DO MAKE A LARGER
ALLOCATION THAT WOULD THAT WOULD
BE MY RECOMMENDATION- TO SIMPLY
TAKE. YOU KNOW THE PREVIOUS
GROUP OF. APPLICATIONS AND THEN-
YOU KNOW APPLY THE NEW MONIES
AND FIGURE OUT YOU KNOW WHICH OF
THOSE WOULD MAKE THE GRADE.
VENTURA DE SEGUIR. CHANGE THANK
YOU. APPRECIATE THANK YOU GREAT
. OKAY THE. RETURN ANY MORE.
WESTON'S SUGGESTIONS. ON ON
ISSUES. MEMBERS KNOW LITTLE
PRICKS. OKAY. ALL RIGHT THEN WE
WILL MOVE ON WE'RE HOLDING HIS
ITEM OPEN OBVIOUSLY WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO THE REST OF THE
DISCUSSION ITEMS- ISSUE
EIGHTEEN. IS OFFICE OF TRAFFIC
SAFETY PROGRAM PLANNING AND
OUTREACH AND OUR OFFICE OF A-
TRAFFIC- IN OUR STATE
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY. WHO WILL
WHO WILL BE SPEAKING THEIR
APARTMENTS ROONEY YES CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES GOING WONDERFUL
WONDERFUL GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS I AM
OFFERING YOU DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF TRAFFIC
SAFETY ALSO WITH ME TODAY I HAVE
NOT CANNELLA ARE ACTING DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF TECHNOLOGY AND
FACIAL. THE O. T. S. OUR OFFICE
OF TRAFFIC SAFETY IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR APPLYING FOR AND RECEIVING
CALIFORNIA'S FEDERAL TRAFFIC
SAFETY FUNDS FOR COORDINATING
CALIFORNIA'S HIGHWAY SAFETY
PROGRAMS EACH YEAR WE DEVELOP A
HIGHWAY SAFETY PLAN IDENTIFYING
THE CRITICAL HIGHWAY SAFETY
PROBLEMS IN THE STATE. AND THE
MOST EFFECTIVE COUNTERMEASURES
TO ADDRESS THEM AND TO BE CLEAR-
TS ADMINISTERS THE BEHAVIORAL
HIGHWAY SAFETY PROGRAMS AS
OPPOSED TO ENGINEERING AND
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND THROUGH THIS
FORMULA GRANT FUNDING CALIFORNIA
RECEIVED FROM THE NATIONAL
HIGHWAY TRANSPORTATION SAFETY
ADMINISTRATION THE O. T. S.
ANNUALLY FUNDS OVER ONE HUNDRED
MILLION IN INNOVATIVE EVIDENCE.
BASED EDUCATION AND ENFORCEMENT
PROGRAMS AND TECHNOLOGIES
DESIGNED TO MAKE CALIFORNIA
ROADWAYS SAFER NOW HISTORICALLY
WE PROCESSED APPROXIMATELY THREE
TO FOUR HUNDRED GRANT
APPLICATIONS WITH THIRTY FOR
PERMANENT POSITIONS- TS IS
EXPECTING TO RECEIVE A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE 25%
INCREASE IN FUNDING FROM THE
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT AND
JOBS ACT. ALSO KNOWN AS THE
BIPARTISAN INFRASTRUCTURE LAW.
THESE INCREASE FUNDING LEVELS
COULD NOT COME AT A BETTER TIME
THE NATION IS EXPERIENCING A
CRISIS ON OUR ROADWAYS
CALIFORNIA LOST OVER THIRTY
EIGHT HUNDRED PEOPLE ON OUR
ROADS IN TWENTY TWENTY. THIS IS
A THREE POINT 4% INCREASE FROM
TWENTY NINETEEN NHTSA THE
NATIONAL HIGHWAY TRANSPORTATION
SAFETY ADMINISTRATION IS
ESTIMATING THAT IN THE FIRST
NINE MONTHS OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. CALIFORNIA IS PROJECTED TO
BE THE SEVENTEENTH 2% INCREASE
FROM THE SAME PERIOD IN TWENTY
TWENTY. WE ARE SEEING ALARMING
INCREASES IN FATAL CRASHES
INVOLVING ALCOHOL A 20% INCREASE
IN TWENTY TWENTY ON TWENTY
NINETEEN AND PEDESTRIAN
FATALITIES INCREASED IN
CALIFORNIA OVER THE PAST DECADE
BY OVER. SIXTY SIX ZERO PERCENT.
SPEEDING AND ACCESSIBLE. HAS
ALSO BEEN A SIGNAL PROBLEM
DURING THE EARLY PHASE OF THE
CAN DOWN AND REMAIN. PROBLEMATIC
SO THE- AT INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENT AND JOBS ACT FURTHER
CONTAINS NEW PROGRAM
REQUIREMENTS IT ADDS NEW
NATIONAL PRIOR TO SAFETY
ALLOWABLE USES FOR SOME OF THE
GRANT PROGRAM. HOWEVER THERE IS
A NEW CRITICAL PROVISION THAT
REQUIRES STATES TO PROVIDE A
COMPREHENSIVE DATA DRIVEN
TRAFFIC SAFETY PROGRAM THAT
RESULTS FROM MEANINGFUL PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION AND ENGAGEMENT
FROM AFFECTED COMMUNITIES
PARTICULARLY THOSE MOST
SIGNIFICANTLY SIGNIFICANTLY
IMPACTED BY TRAFFIC CRASHES
RESULTING IN INJURIES AND
FATALITIES NOW IN RESPONSE. US
DEPARTMENT TRANSPORTATION HAS
RECENTLY RELEASED A FIRST EVER
NATIONAL ROADWAY SAFETY STRATEGY
WHICH IS ROOTED IN THE SAY
SYSTEM APPROACH TO SAFETY SO
WHILE THE FOUNDATIONAL
PRINCIPLES THE FEDERAL
COMMITMENT AND THE RESOURCES ARE
IN PLACE TO BEGIN WITH REVERSING
THE TROUBLING TRENDS YOUR
EXPERIENCE IN CALIFORNIA THE- TS
IS NOT APPROPRIATELY RESOURCE
FOR ORGANIZED AFRAID THIS. HOUSE
ROLE NEEDED TO LEAD- NEW EFFORTS
NECESSARY TO DRIVE DOWN OUR
INTELLIGENCE AND SERIOUS
INJURIES TO OUR REQUEST BEFORE
YOU ARE AN INCREASE IN OUR
FEDERAL SPENDING FOR AND
TRANSPORTATION FUNDS ACCORDING
TO HIRE NEW POSITIONS TO EXPAND-
TSS OPERATES. TO INCREASE OUR
OUTRAGE RESISTING AND
PROSPECTIVE GRANTEES BY
MAXIMIZING AVAILABLE FUNDING TO
ENHANCE THE SAFETY. OF
CALIFORNIA ROAD USERS AND. OF
COURSE THE MEAT THE NEW. I A A.
ARE THE RECORD. OTIS IS ALSO
WERE. SPEECH TO ON TO COVER. FOR
ONE TIMES WE- AND FURNITURE OF
ANY. AND HI WORKFORCE AND THE
REQUEST WILL ALSO ALIGN THE MTS
FEDERAL SPENDING FORTY WITH THE
FEDERAL FUNDING RECEIVED BY O.
T. S. EACH YEAR AND HELP THE
STATE'S MEETS OUR FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS IT WILL ALSO ALLOW
IT'S YES TO EXPAND. ALL FEDERAL
FUNDS AWARDED TO IT I- BY NHTSA
FOR THE STATE TO GRANT PROGRAMS
IN B. O. T. S. WILL BE ABLE TO
DEVELOP AND- OUR HIGHWAY SAFETY
PLAN AND MAXIMIZE THE USE OF OUR
FEDERAL FUNDING TO SAVE A LIFE
AND I JUST WANT TO CLOSE MY-
SPEAKING TO THE COMMENTS-
COMMITTEE STAFF THAT WAS. IN THE
AGENDA RELATIVE TO SPECIFIC
OUTCOMES YOU CAN EXPECT EXPECT
WITH- THE PASSAGE OF THIS
PROPOSAL. THIS PROPOSAL WILL
POSITION THE- TS PERFORM ITS
LEADERSHIP ROLE IN ADVANCING
TRAFFIC SAFETY PREPARING
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES FOR THE
SUCCESSFUL ADOPTION OF THE SAFE
SYSTEM PRINCIPLES DEVELOPING AND
ADMINISTERING NEW AND EXISTING
TRAFFIC SAFETY PROGRAMS WITH IT
AT ALL ONES TO ENSURE OUR MOST
VULNERABLE UNDERSERVED
POPULATIONS ARE PRIORITIZED. AND
WITH THIS INCREASE STOPPING THE-
TS WILL HAVE RESOURCES TO FOCUS
ON OUR TEN PRIORITY PROGRAM
AREAS BUT ALSO THAT ARE
COMMUNITY OUTREACH ENGAGE AND
POLICY DISCUSSIONS OF A LOCAL
STATE AND FEDERAL LEVELS. CREATE
INCONVENIENCE HAPTIC SAFETY
STAKEHOLDER FORMS DROP. EFFORTS
TO CREATE A SAFETY CULTURE AND
PROMOTE EQUITY IN ORDER TO PASS
ISN'T OF COURSE ADVANCE
CALIFORNIA'S VERSION OF ZERO
RAILWAY STATS THE- TS WILL WORK
WITH. AT THE REGIONAL AND LOCAL
LEVELS TO IDENTIFY LOCAL AND
COMMUNITY TRAFFIC SAFETY NEEDS.
AND HELP TO FACILITATE- EFFORTS
TO TRACK SAFETY THE ACTIONS WILL
INCUR THE WALL OF TS GRANT. AND
MORE FROM FUNDS OUT STATE ALSO.
SAVE LIVES. I WANT TO THANK YOU
AND HAVE I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER OF
THE QUESTIONS OF THE- THANK YOU
. OKAY FINANCE. THE AVAILABLE
ONE TO MAKE ANY COMMENTS
BENJAMIN FOG FROM THE FINANCE
NOTHING BAD AT THIS TIME. OKAY
AND- R. L. A. O. IS THAT MISS
ROW. YES THIS IS SERVICE UNITS
ROUTE- WE HAVE NO ISSUES WITH
THIS PROPOSAL OKAY. OKAY MEMBERS
ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. ON
THIS ISSUE NONE OKAY ALL RIGHT
WELL- THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE PRESENTATION OF MISS ROONEY
APPRECIATE THAT AND THE WILL BE
WILL BE NONE OKAY THANK YOU NEXT
AFTER ISSUE EIGHTEEN- NINETEEN
AS OUR TRANSPORTATION EQUITY
WORKLOAD. AND THE CTC WILL BE
PRESENTING. IS THAT MISS TAYLOR
. YES THANK YOU FOR THE MEMORIES
WILL OPEN ALL SECRET GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARED WRESTLING
SENATORS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TODAY AND
HE SINCERELY SEEK A YEAR AFTER
FOR THE CALIFORNIA.
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION. AS A
RESULT. THE COMMISSION'S
RESPONSIBLE FOR PROGRAMMING
ALLOCATING TRANSPORTATION FUNDS
TO PROJECTS WE HAVE ELEVEN
COMMISSIONERS AND JUNE I'M GOING
LEGISLATIVE EXHIBITION
COMMISSIONERS ONE OF WHO IS
SENATOR NEWMAN IT'S GOOD TO SEE
TODAY'S ENTERTAINMENT. HE
RECOGNIZE HIM A RADIO- THE
COMMISSION IS SEEKING
200-180-0041 ADDITIONAL POSITION
TO SUPPORT WORKLOAD RELATED TO
TRANSPORTATION EQUITY THE
COMMISSION ASSIGNED TO CENTER
EQUITY IS A KEY FACTOR IN
TRANSPORTATION DECISION MAKING
USING A REDIRECTING EXISTING
POSITIONS- PARTITIONS FROM
CALTRANS TO SUPPORT THIS WORK IN
RECENT YEARS REDIRECTING
RESOURCES IN THIS MANNER ALLOW
THE COMMISSION TO EXPAND ITS
OUTREACH ACTIVITIES WITH
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AND DOCTORS FIRST ERROR RACIAL
EQUITY STATEMENT AND ESTABLISHED
IN EQUITY ADVISORY ROUNDTABLE.
WELL THIS TEMPORARY SOLUTION HAS
WORKED IN THE SHORT TERM AN
ONGOING I MEAN TATIAN AND
STAFFING RESOURCES IS NEEDED TO
CONTINUE THIS WORK WHILE ALSO
SELLING COMMISSIONS ADDITIONAL
RESPONSIBILITIES THE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES WILL ALLOW THE
COMMISSION TO CONTINUE IN OUR
EACH ACTIVITIES AND CONTRIBUTE
TO THE FORTHCOMING INTERAGENCY
AND FORTY EMPLOYEES REGIONALLY
WHICH WILL BE ADMINISTERED IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH CALTRANS AND
THE TRANSPORTATION AGENCY.
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES WILL ALSO
ALLOW THE COMMISSION TO RESTORE
SOME FOCUSED ON THEIR
OBLIGATIONS INCLUDING OTHER
RADIO REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION
PLANS AND SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITY
STRATEGIES TO ENSURE CONSISTENCY
WITH STATE POLICIES AND
COMMERCIAL. LINES TRIBALLY IS
ALSO TO COMMISSION GUIDELINES.
MEANING ENGAGE IN AN EFFORTS ON
TOPICS LIKE. THE MASTER PLAN AND
AGING. MICROMOLAR IN SOME MOBILE
OPTION. STATEWIDE RACE STRATEGY
AND ZERO EMISSION. THE PLAN. AND
LAUNCH PERFORM MEASURE.
PROCESSES FOR THE CAN SIGN FOR.
THANK YOU FOR MAKING. TODAY AND
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. GREAT THANK YOU MISS
TAYLOR- WE WILL NOW MOVE ON OWN
TERMS OF THIS ISSUE TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. MARTIN
DOUG THIS TIME THANK YOU OKAY
AND THEN WE'LL MOVE ON TO THE L.
A. O. THE MEMBERS FRANK MENACE
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE I'M OUR OFFICE HAS NO
CONCERNS WITH THIS PROPOSAL BUT
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
OKAY THANK YOU OKAY WE'LL COME
ON TO OUR MEMBERS ANY COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS. YES WITH SENATOR
NEWMAN I JUST WANT TO SAY HOW
MUCH DID YOU PAY HER TO HA HA I
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
ACKNOWLEDGING. BUT IT IT YOU
KNOW IT IT ACTUALLY HAS BEEN A
PLEASURE WORKING WITH ALL OF THE
CDC STAFF AND SO I'M LOOKING FOR
TO CONTINUE TO DO SO. THANK YOU
. SENATOR CRITICIZING ANY
COMMENTS NONE OF THE SENATE OKAY
GREAT OKAY UP AGAIN THANK YOU
MISS TAYLOR- FOR TAKING THE TIME
TO MAKE THE PRESENTATION
APPRECIATE ALL YOUR WORK WE'LL
MOVE ON NOW TO ISSUE TWENTY
AUDITS AND INVESTIGATIONS
WORKLOAD TRANSFER OF CALTRANS-
LET'S SEE WHO'S GOING TO DO THAT
IS THAT MISTER DUNCAN. YES OKAY
MISTER CALDERON MOVES THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR SENATORS A GOOD
AFTERNOON MENTION KEEP DUMPING
ABSENT BUDGET OFFICER BOB THIS
PROPOSAL CALTRANS IS REQUESTING
A NET ZERO TRANSFER OF SIX
PERMANENT FULL TIME POSITION AND
THE ASSOCIATED FUNDING FROM THE
INDEPENDENT OFFICE OF ALL THE
FUNDING BASS FISHING TO THE
CALTRANS ADMINISTRATION PROGRAM
TO RE ESTABLISH AN INTERNAL
AUDIT OFFICE WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT- AS NOTED IN YOUR
AGENDA MATERIALTODAY IN AN
OFFICE OF OUR INVESTIGATION THE
DALLAS WITH THE PASSAGE OF THE
ROAD REPAIRS ON THE BILL THE ACT
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN- ONLY.
SENATE BILL ONE- AND THIS OFFICE
WAS GIVEN THE AUTHORITY TO
EXERCISE ALL RESPONSIBILITIES
FOR MAINTAINING A FULL GO
INDEPENDENT AND OBJECTIVE AUDIT
INVESTIGATIONS PROGRAM I JUST AT
THE START OF THIS THE NEW OFFICE
THERE CALTRANS HAD- IT EXISTING
AUDIT DIVISION OF OUR
INVESTIGATION I RESOURCES OF
FORTY EIGHT THE VISION- THOSE
POSITIONS WILL TRANSFER OVER TO
THIS MAN AND OFFICE AS WELL AS
AN ADDITIONAL NEW FROM THE
DISHES WERE PROVIDED TO THE NEW
OFFICE FORMS OF THAT STATURE
DRIVEN WORKFLOWS- RECENTLY- THE
CALTRANS PROGRAM ALONG WITH THE
IN THAT OFFICE OTHER THAN THAT
THE ASIAN I CONDUCTED A WORKBOOK
STUDIES HAVE REVIEW THE WORKLOAD
THAT ARE IN AN OFFICE REFORM
ABLE I'M SEVERAL ADMINISTRATIVE
FUNCTIONS AS SEPARATE FROM THE
ACTUAL AUDIT OVERSIGHT
ACTIVITIES THE OFFICE IS A
MANDATED TO PERFORM- F. AS A
RESULT OF THE VISION AND AGREE
WAS MADE THAT THAT THAT WORK
WILL STRICTLY TO THE ADMIN
FUNCTION. OF EACH BACK TO THAT
CALTRANS ADMIN JUST REAL
ESTABLISHES BOB BOB SO WE CAN DO
THE FUNCTION AND LEAVE THE
RESOURCES AND THE WORKFLOW
WITHIN THE FEDERAL SO CONTINUE
TO GROW THE OVERSIGHT ACTIVITIES
THE OFFICE.
ON CALTRANS OFFICES AT THE REST
OF THE STATUTE I WITHOUT I KNOW
DIANE ANTHONY FROM THE END OF
THAT OFFICE OUR INVESTIGATION
ALSO ONLINE AND- TO GATHER WE
WILL BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. WE
APPRECIATE YOUR CALL. OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE DO YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS
. WE WERE JAMES OR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE JUST TO
NOTE THAT THIS PROPOSAL IS THE
RESULT OF EXTENSIVE NEGOCIAR
EXTENSIVE CONVERSATIONS BETWEEN
FINANCE- THE INSPECTOR GENERAL'S
OFFICE AND CALTRANS. PUBLIC TAKE
A QUESTION. OKAY AND THE L. A.
O. THAT MISTER JIMENEZ. YES
TWENTY MINUTES AGO LEGISLATIVE
ANALYSTS OFFICE- NO COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS ABOUT THIS PROPOSAL BUT
AGAIN I HAVE TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE MAY
HAVE. OKAY OKAY I DO I DO HAVE A
QUESTION WITH REGARDS TO THE
ISSUE OF WHETHER OR NOT THERE IS
A CONFLICT OF INTEREST PROBLEM-
NOT QUITE SURE IT STARTED
THERE'S AN INTERNAL INDEPENDENT
OFFICE OF AUDITS AND THEN WE
WENT TO AN INTERNAL AUDITS
OFFICE WITHIN THE ADMINISTRATION
SO I GOT TIME A LITTLE BIT
CONFUSED HERE- HOW THIS. OF HOW
WE MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S NO
CONFLICT OF INTEREST BUT YET.
PROVIDE FOR THE AUDIT TEAM NEEDS
THAT WE HAVE BOTH AND TERMINALLY
AS WELL AS- EXTERNALLY SO WHO
WANTS TO. TAKE ANOTHER STAB AT
EXPLAINING THAT. WITH THAT
MISTER DUNCAN. OKAY ALL I CAN
CHECK IN BILL AND I KNOW DAM IS
ONLINE AS WELL I WHAT WE DO HAVE
AS PART OF THIS OVERALL
AGREEMENT DISCUSSION WHEN WE ARE
DO I DELINEATE THOSE
ADMINISTRATIVE FUNCTIONS- FROM
BACK TO CALTRANS. FOR WITHIN OUR
IT WILL BE REFERRED TO AS AN
INTERNAL AUDIT DIVISION WE DO
HAVE A- A MEMORANDUM MEMORANDUM
OF UNDERSTANDING TO BE ABLE TO
STRIP IT DOWN BY WHAT THEIR
WORKLOAD IS SO WE CAN SPECIFY-
TO THE BASE BECAUSE REDUCE ANY
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT A CONFLICT
OF INTEREST HELLO THEM HAVE. A
LOT MORE- BACKGROUND RELATED TO
SOME OF THOSE THAT WORK BETTER
THAN THAT THE- DISCUSSION FOR
ONE OF THE- WHAT. ABOUT AFTER.
I'M SURE YOU GO GO AHEAD I GOOD
AFTERNOON- CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBER- NAME IS DIANE AND SHE
WITH THE ALL OF AND GENERAL
OFFICE- SO YEAH IT IN TERMS OF
CONFLICT OF INTEREST- THAT'S ONE
OF THE PRIMARY PURPOSES OF
TRYING- PROPOSING TO TRANSFER
SOME OF THE ACTIVITIES THAT OUR
OFFICE CURRENTLY DOES- THESE
ADMINISTRATIVE- RELATED-
ACTIVITIES ACTUALLY- IN KIND OF.
IMPOSE A CONFLICT OF INTEREST
WITH OUR OFFICE AND BECAUSE WE
DO CERTAIN ADMINISTRATIVE
FUNCTIONS AND REVIEWS AND THEN
WE TURN AROUND AND WE COME BACK
AND AUDIT THOSE SAME ACTIVITIES-
AND SO THAT'S ONE OF THE PRIMARY
PURPOSES OF OUR THE PROPOSAL IS
TO TRANSFER THOSE MORE
ADMINISTRATIVE FUNCTIONS OUT OF
OUR OFFICE- IN BACK TO CALTRANS
. OKAY IBM ANY QUESTIONS. GO
AHEAD SENATOR HATCH I GUESS I
SURE THAT YOURS CONFUSION AND
MAYBE IT'S BASED ON THE WORDING
IN OUR ANALYSIS SO- TO THE
ADMINISTRATION'S INDICATED THAT
THIS REQUEST WOULD ALLOW
CALTRANS TO RE ESTABLISH AN
INTERNAL AUDITS OFFICE WHICH AT
LEAST ON ITS FACE MIGHT POSE. A
CONFLICT OF THE INTENT OF SB ONE
MIGHT MY UNDERSTANDING HERE-
FROM HIS INTERVIEWS IS THAT YOU
ARE SEEING A TO BRING BACK SOME
ADMINISTRATIVE FUNCTIONS- THAT.
IT MAKES MORE SENSE TO HAVE
HOUSE TO CALTRANS- SO THERE'S NO
CONFUSION IF AND WHEN THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL THEN RE ON
IT'S THAT IS THAT CORRECTED I
THINK I GOT IT IS INTERESTING.
YEP YEP EXACTLY RIGHT YES WHAT
ARE MY OPTIONS ARE- FIVE PRIMARY
I DIDN'T OVERSIGHT FUNCTIONS
THAT ARE SPELLED OUT IN
GOVERNMENT CODE- WHICH IS YOU
KNOW A PART OF THE S. B. ****
ADDITION OF AB WAS WE WILL
CONTINUE TO DO THOSE A 100% THAT. WAS ASKED TO LEAVE AYE WITHIN
OUR OFFICE. I THINK I CLEAR
THANK YOU FOR. WHAT OKAY TO THE
COURTESY ANY COMMON TO QUESTIONS
SO JUST BE. KHURRAM HIM DOING
THE ARITHMETIC- DOES. DOES THE-
I. O. A I. OFFICE END UP WITH.
FIFTY TWO NET POSITIONS LEFT OR
WHAT IS THE NUMBER IN OR MAYBE
THAT'S ALTERED BY ADDITIONAL
BUDGET- ITEMS THAT ARE COMING
THROUGH DOES ANYBODY KNOW THAT
IT IS HEREBY ADD EVERYTHING UP
IT LOOKS LIKE FIFTY EIGHT
POSITIONS WERE CREATED. AND NOW
WE'RE SUBTRACTING SIX TO BRING
THEM BACK. RIGHT GO AHEAD YES I
BELIEVE I BELIEVE THAT IS THE
CASE HE I DON'T HAVE THE NUMBERS
IN THERE AND STUFF. NOTAR DANNY
YES SENATOR THAT IS CORRECT WITH
THIS WHEN THE ORIGINAL TOPIC
WILL BE OFFICE WAS ORIGINALLY
RESOURCE FROM THE BEGINNING OF
THE FIFTY EIGHT ATTACHMENT OF
SIX HOURS WOULD BE AND THAT'S
OUR SAVINGS ARE MET WITH AMOUNT
OF FIFTY TWO LIMITING THEM-
OFFICE IN THOSE FIFTY TWO AS FAR
AS WE KNOW ARE FILLED- FUNDED
FIELD POSITION STILL TO THIS DAY
. THAT THEY ARE RESOURCES WITHIN
THAT THE ARE AT THE END OF THAT
OFFICE YEAH. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
. THANK YOU. OKAY A REAL ANYMORE
SO THE TOYOTA TUNDRA K. NO JOKE
GOOD QUESTIONS WE CAN BE CLEAR
ABOUT THIS OKAY- OKAY MISTER
DUNCAN AND- IS ANTHONY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
ISSUE TWENTY ONE. ARE THAT'S
EMERGENCY NINE ELEVEN AND
DISPATCH AUDIO LOGGING SYSTEM
REPLACEMENT OF- SO WE COULD
COULD WE HAVE A CHP. PLEASE MAKE
A PRESENTATION. IT AFTERNOON
MA'AM SHAGARI DEPUTY
COMMISSIONER WITH THE CHP WOMEN
TODAY AS ASSISTANT CHIEF MIKE
ALVAREZ WERE REPRESENTING ON
BEHALF OF COMMISSIONER. PETER
TODAY GRATEFUL FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS THIS
PROPOSAL THE ISSUE WILL BE
DISCUSSING TODAY IS THE CDC'S
EMERGENCY NINE ONE ONE DISPATCH
AUDIO LOBBY SYSTEM REPLACEMENT
REQUEST OF THE CBS REQUESTING
TWENTY ONE MILLION OVER SIX
WIRES FROM THE MOTOR VEHICLE
COUNTS REPLACE ARE ALSO THE NINE
ONE ONE PUBLIC SAFETY RADIO
COMMUNICATIONS AUDIO BLOGGING
SYSTEMS CURRENTLY USE. THIS
REQUEST ALSO INCLUDES A
COMPONENT THAT WILL MEET
CONTINUITY OF OPERATIONS IN THE
EVENT OF A CATASTROPHIC EVENT OR
FAILURE AS WAY BACKGROUND CG
OPERATES TWENTY FOUR MEDICATION
CENTERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
THE TWENTY FOUR COMMUNICATION
CENTER SERVE THE PUBLIC AND IT
SEES AS PRIMARY PUBLIC SAFETY
ANSWERING POINTS RESPONDING TO
NINE ONE ONE EMERGENCY CALLS AND
RADIO TRANSMISSIONS. ALL OF
THESE COMMUNICATIONS CENTERS- IN
QUICK FOR THE PRIMARY REDUNDANT
AUDIO LOGGING SYSTEM TO CAPTURE
NINE ONE ONE AND MISSION
CRITICAL TELEPHONE CALLS AND
RADIO TRANSMISSIONS BETWEEN CHP
DISPATCHERS THE PUBLIC SEES THE
FIELD PERSONNEL AND OUR ALLIES
AGENCIES OTHER THAN APARTMENTS
CURRENT AUDIO LOGGING SYSTEM WAS
INITIALLY BACK IN FY. TWENTY
FOUR OR TWENTY FOURTEEN FIFTY-
THE USEFUL LIFE. OF THE SYSTEM
IS FIVE SEVEN AND THEREFORE. OF
THE CURRENCY IN USE THAT THE END
OF LIFE- OF THIS THIRTY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. THE CURRENT
VENDOR WILL NO LONGER SUPPORT
THE SYSTEM- THIS INNOCENT COURT
INCLUDES SOFTWARE TECHNICAL
SUPPORT HARDWARE SUPPORT AND
SECURITY PATCHING. ASSOCIATED
SPARE PARTS ON SITE SUPPORT AND
TRAINING. ADDITIONALLY THE
EXISTING SYSTEM DOES NOT MEET
THE REQUIRED DISASTER RECOVERY
STANDARDS SET FORTH BY THE
DEPARTMENT IN OUR INFORMATION
SECURITY OFFICER- ONCE
IDENTIFIED WE ANTICIPATE THIS
REPLACEMENT SYSTEM WILL HAVE
INCREASED FUNCTIONALITY AND
ALLOW THE C. STREET TO BETTER
MANAGE ITS AUDIO LOGS. OR
INVESTIGATIONS AND EVIDENTIARY
PURPOSES WE ALSO FALL INTO STATE
REPLACEMENT AUDIO LOGGING SYSTEM
WILL MEET. OUR DISASTER RECOVERY
REQUIREMENTS AND ENSURE COP AND
UNION SERVICE TO THE PUBLIC
SHOULD ANY OF THE COMMUNICATIONS
CENTER IS EXPERIENCING A
CATASTROPHIC INCIDENT OR
FAILURE. OF THIS FUNDING WILL
ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT TO IDENTIFY
AND PROCURE A MISSION CRITICAL
AUDIO LOGGING SYSTEM PRIOR TO
THE CURRENT SYSTEMS END OF LIFE.
AND ALIGN WITH EACH BEACHWOOD
DISASTER RECOVERY STANDARDS
INDUSTRY STANDARDS BEST
PRACTICES AND NEXT GEN NINE ONE
ONE WE. WILL DO OUR BEST ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU. THANK YOU
VERY. I'M DO WE HAVE ANY
COMMENTS FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. SEE WELLS BARNETT
FINANCE- JUST WANT TO SAY THIS
IS- THIS A REQUEST REPRESENTS
SOME SORT OF A STANDARD BASED-
WORKLOAD- BASELINE- THAT IS
IMPORTANT THE OPERATION OF THE
CHP. AND IN JUST REPRESENTS THE
TECHNOLOGY NEEDS THAT THEY NEED
TO DO THEIR- TO DO THEIR THEIR
MISSION. OKAY AND- THE L. A. L.
ANY COMMENTS. WELL YOU THIS ROAD
THE L. A. L. WE HAVE NO COMMENTS
WITH THIS PROPOSAL. OKAY SOUNDS
VERY GOOD- THANK YOU MR I'M
SORRY SEAN YOUR LAST NAME AGAIN
. THREE THREE OKAY THANK YOU
MISTER JURY AND- MR OF OTHERS-
JUST ONE SMALL QUESTION HERE
WITH THE TIMING OF THIS- I
ASSUME THAT WERE IT IN TOP ON
TIME TO FOR THAT REPLACEMENT TO
BE MADE. OF BEFORE IT BECOMES.
NONFUNCTIONAL YES YEAH WE ARE WE
HAVE SEVERAL THAT ARE COMING UP
WILL BE EXPIRED ON FIFTEEN OF
THE TWENTY FOUR SYSTEMS WILL BE
EXPIRED OR ARE EXPIRING SO WE
WILL DEFINITELY MAKE THOSE A
PRIORITY IN PRIORITIZE AS WE
WERE OFTEN USES AND OVER WHAT
PERIOD OF TIME. THE EXPECT THAT.
MORE OR LESS- THE END OF THE
PROPOSAL WILL END UP IN A YEAR'S
FISCAL YEARS TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY
EIGHT. OKAY. OKAY ALL RIGHT WELL
THANK YOU- BOTH FOR THE
PRESENTATION- WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON NOW TO ISSUE TWENTY TWO
THE ENTERPRISE CONTENT
MANAGEMENT PROJECT AND THIS WAS
THE DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES
. LET'S VENTURE IN THAT MISTER
MISTER GORDON. YES WE'VE GOT- R.
G. BUDGET OFFICER WILL BE
PRESENTING FRESHER OKAY ALL
RIGHT MISTER SCOTT GO AHEAD.
CHECK OUT OF YOUR CHECK NUMBERS
MY NAME IS LEE SCOTT CHIEF
BUDGET OFFICER FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES I'M
HERE TODAY WITH DIRECTOR STEVE
GORDON. WE JUST HAVE ONE ISSUE A
ONE SPRING FINALS THAT ARE ON
THE AGENDA FOR DISCUSSION TODAY
THE ENTERPRISE CONTENT
MANAGEMENT PROJECT. SO DEVIOUS
REQUESTING A TOTAL OF FIVE AND A
HALF MILLION IN FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE FOR THE
FROM THE MOTOR VEHICLE ACCOUNT
FOR PLANNING AND IMPLEMENTATION
ACTIVITIES. ASSOCIATED WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE FEDERATED
ENTERPRISE CONTENT MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM THAT WILL INTEGRATE WITH
VARIOUS DEPARTMENTAL SYSTEMS
THIS PROJECT WILL ALLOW THE DMV
TO CONSOLIDATE DOCUMENT
RESOURCES BY MAINTAINING A
CENTRALIZED REPOSITORY THAT
INTEGRATES WITH EXISTING
SYSTEMS. THE C. OF SOCIABLE
STREAMLINED BUSINESS PROCESSES
WHILE INCREASING DATA SECURITY.
THE PROPOSAL TO HAVE A GREATER
AND SOFTWARE SOLUTION WILL MEET
THE OBJECTIVES AND BUSINESS
FUNCTIONAL REQUIREMENTS. AS
DOCUMENTED IN THE CD STAGE.
ALTERNATIVE ANALYSIS AS REQUIRED
BY PAL YOUR PROJECT APPROVAL
LIFECYCLE PROCESS. THE COST OF
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE AND BEYOND ARE BEING
ESTIMATED THROUGH THE POWER
PROCESS WHICH IS CURRENTLY IN
STAGE ONE AND TWO. IT IS
ESTIMATED TO HAVE A STAGE FOR
COMPLETED BY SEPTEMBER TWENTY
FROM TEARS OF THIS FALL. HOWEVER
AS WITH ALL PROJECTS OF THIS
SCOPE REQUIREMENTS MAY CHANGE AS
THE PROJECT MOVES FORWARD- WE
ARE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS PERTAINING THIS
REQUEST THANK YOU. OKAY. THANK
YOU MISTER SCOTT OF DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. METHODIST SENIOR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- WE FULLY
SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND THE L. A. O. L. A.
O. MISS ROW. ENGAGE SHARE I WE
HAVE NO ISSUES WITH PROPOSAL.
HEY RICH IS MOVING RIGHT ALONG
HERE- MEMBERS YES PLEASE GO HAVE
A REALLY MY QUESTION WOULD THE
POWER PRCESS YOU WHAT THE
ACRONYM HELSTON FOR. HELLO SIR I
HAVE A POOR RECORD. RUBLE
LIFECYCLE ITSELF RIGHT PROCESS
SUPPORTED BY CD CDT THE COMPANY
PHARMACOLOGY TO REQUIREMENTS AND
WE GO THROUGH I THINK IT IT HAS
OF LEGISLATIVE ORANGE- PROJECTS
CONFIDED AND ANTECEDENT THANK
YOU. WELCOME GOT IT HELLO BERMAN
OKAY NOPE NOT NOT ON THIS ISSUE
SEARCH LOCAL HAD. THANK YOU
MEASURE IT THERE'S ALL FOUR OF
US ACRONYMS IN THE ON THIS
PARTICULAR PAGE ONLY WHEN I
REALLY RECOGNIZES DMB. OF COULD
YOU GIVE JUST MAYBE A COUPLE OF
EXAMPLES OF THE CONTENT THAT YOU
WOULD BE CONSOLIDATED IN A
SINGLE REPOSITORY IN RIGHT
THERE'S GENERAL DESCRIPTIONS AND
ACRONYMS IN HERE- IT OBVIOUSLY
WE ALL KNOW A DMV DOES BUT- I'M
JUST. YOU SURE SENATE MANY TAKE
THAT STEVE GORDON DIRECTOR OUR
MOTOR VEHICLES ALL THE GIANTS
FOR THE PREVIOUS YEAR AND
ACRONYMS AND OTHERS IN THERE
GETS ITS STATE BUSINESS SO WE
USE A LOT WHAT THE WHAT THE
SYSTEM IS SEEKING TO DO IS
FAIRLY COMMON IN IN IN THE
TECHNOLOGY WORLD THE ON THE AREA
THAT YOU COME FROM I COME FROM
ACTUALLY FROM YOUR DISTRICT BUT
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS THAT
EACH ONE OF THE SILOS OF THE
ENVY OF BEEN BUILT ON THEIR OWN
FOUNDATION AND WHAT ENTERPRISE
CONTENT MANAGEMENT DOES IT
ALLOWS US TO. REACH AND FEDERATE
A DRIVER SAFETY PROGRAM THAT WE
HAVE THAT ADMINISTERS HEARING
FOR PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN CAUGHT
UP IN IMPROPER DRIVING BEHAVIOR
WITH OUR LICENSING SYSTEM WITH
OUR REGISTRATION SYSTEM WITH OUR
INVESTIGATION SYSTEM ALL OF
WHICH WERE SORT OF BUILT
INDEPENDENTLY OF EACH OTHER SO
BY HAVING AN ENTERPRISE CONTENT
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM THAT SITS ON
TOP OF THOSE AND ALLOWS US NOW
TO LOOK AT THAT AS ONE BIG PIECE
OF DATA SO THAT YOU DON'T HAVE
TO PHYSICALLY GO OR HAVE A
SEPARATE LOG INTO CREDENTIALS.
AND FOR EACH SYSTEM YOU NEED TO
YOU NEED TO ACCESS IN SOME CASES
LIKE OUR INVESTIGATORS THEY NEED
TO ACCESS ALL OF THE SISTERS
FROM THEIR DOING INVESTIGATIONS
ARE COMMON LICENSEE POLICY I
NEED TO SEE WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
DRIVER SAFETY WHICH TODAY
REQUIRES A SEPARATE SET OF
CREDENTIALS A SEPARATE SET OF
SERVERS THAT ARE NOT ALWAYS THAT
WAY COULD BE IN A DATA CENTER
AND SO THAT'S WHAT WE'RE SEEKING
TO SOLVE BY USING MODERN
TECHNOLOGY THAT SPANS ALL THESE
INDEPENDENT. SILOS WITHIN THE
DMB. DO SEE USES FOR IT B. R.
DMV'S. CURRY SCOPE OF DAY. BUT
THAT WOULD BE BETTER IF TO THE
STATE. WHY I THINK THESE TYPES
OF SYSTEMS ARE FAIRLY COMMON IN
THE TECHNOLOGY SPACE I'M SURE
OTHER DEPARTMENTS ARE DOING
SOMETHING SIMILAR WE'RE JUST
TRYING TO GET OUR TEAMS TO STOP
BUILDING THE OTHERS VERTICAL
DISCONNECTED SILOS AND START
LOOKING AT THE BUSINESS MORE
HORIZONTALLY. SO I SUSPECT OTHER
DEPARTMENTS ARE DOING SOMETHING
VERY VERY SIMILAR BUT I CAN'T I
CAN'T SPEAK TO OTHERS IT IS
ASKING THE GENERAL CONTEXT OF A
LOT OF WHAT WE- PURSUE AS
LEGISLATORS OR THOUGHT
OFTENTIMES EDUCATION
INFORMATIONAL PROGRAMS ARE
TRYING TO GO OUT TO FOLKS YOU
KNOW ON A MASS BASIS- AND- IN A
JUST ONE OF THE SYSTEM- BY
CONSULTING THE DATA LIKE THIS
WOULD. WOULD WOULD CREATE THE
ABILITY. TO- YOU KNOW TO
ESSENTIALLY. INTERNALLY WITH THE
N. B. TO DO THAT KIND OF THING-
NOTIFICATIONS TO PEOPLE- YOU
KNOW WHAT. YEAH HE TO A BOOK
ABOUT- NOT NECESSARILY RELATED
SERVICES BUT STATE SERVICES THAT
ARE AVAILABLE. THE EIGHT STRIKES
ME THAT THE SYSTEM WOULDN'T BE
ABLE TO DO THAT RIGHT NOW BASED
ON WHAT YOU'VE SAID AND WHAT'S
IN THE REPORT IN JUST MY GENERAL
UNDERSTANDING OF MAKING A FEW
DIEM BEACON CORY'S RECENTLY
THAT. IF YOU WANT TO KNOW
VEHICLE REGISTRATION HERE IN ONE
PLACE IF YOU WANT TO KNOW-
SOMETHING ELSE IT'LL LOOK IT
SEEMS TO BE A COMPLETE ALMOST A
SEPARATE DATABASES WHAT I'M
HEARING YOU SAY OF VERTICAL
SILOS- YOU DON'T YOU DON'T HAVE
TO GO THAT FAR AND ANSWER THE
QUESTION IF IT'S NOT COME UP I
GUESS I SHOULD PURPOSES
QUESTIONS. THE QUESTIONS LIKE
THAT WITH- THE PHRASE HAS THAT
COME UP. I THINK THAT'S ALWAYS
REALLY LOOKING FOR YES THERE ARE
SOME DATA SHARING- INITIATIVES I
CAN'T THINK OF A SPECIFIC NAME
BUT I THINK THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE IS DRIVING SOME DATA
SHARING INITIATIVES SO THAT
DEPARTMENTS LIKE FOR EXAMPLE WE
SHARE DATA USING A TECHNOLOGY
CALLED SNOWFLAKE. WITH EUROPE
AUTOMOTIVE REPAIRS BECAUSE WE
HAVE A SHARED INTEREST IN MAKING
SURE THAT PEOPLE VEHICLES ARE
BEING SMOG MAKING SURE SMOG I
TESTER NOT BEING BY PASSING BY
HAVING THOSE DATA SHARING
AGREEMENTS THAT ALLOWS US TO
WORK MUCH MORE COLLABORATIVELY
AND WE DO WE SHARE SOME OF OUR
INFORMATION THAT'S SPECIFIC TO
THEIR BUSINESS THEY SHARE SOME
OTHERS. SO WE CAN BETTER
EFFECTUATE OUR GOALS SO WE ARE
DOING YOU KNOW WHAT YOU'RE WHAT
YOU'RE SUGGESTING SENATOR IT'S
NOT ACROSS ALL FACETS OF
GOVERNMENT BENEFITS ACROSS
ADJACENT BUSINESS GREAT THAT'S
HELPFUL TO UNDERSTAND FOR FUTURE
REFERENCE THANK YOU. YOU'RE
WELCOME THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
THANK YOU- THERE WAS A QUESTION
THAT'S BEEN A SUGGESTED THAT
WHAT ARE. THE OUT YOUR COST OF
THE SYSTEM. SO THE ITEM IF YOU
HAVE THE IDEA BECAUSE IF YOU
HAVE THOSE OF THE PROPOSAL. YEP
THAT'S SO. SO JUST TO BE KIND OF
OUR ONLY ASKING- TO FOR THE NEXT
YEARS REQUEST A DOLLARS AND THAT
WILL BE COMING FORWARD. WITH A
FUTURE PROPOSAL. WE WANT TO TRY
TO GET THROUGH THE POWER PROCESS
FIRST AND ONCE WE COMPLETE STAGE
FOUR WILL KNOW HOW MUCH THE OUT
YEARS OF COSTS ARE GOING TO BE I
THINK. WE HAVE SOME ESTIMATES IN
MY BED TO BE CLEAR AND WE WERE
WORKING WITH A CONSULTANT AT
FIRST THAT. I WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE WERE FISCALLY
RESPONSIBLE WITH THIS PROPOSAL
FIRST PICTURE OF WENT THROUGH
CALL AND THEN WE WILL BE COMING
BACK PROBABLY- EITHER IN THE
TEXTURES GOVERNOR'S BUDGET OR IN
EXTREME. CHECK THE MONITOR THERE
IS A JUST A WONDER IS NOT NOT
AND I'M GOING TO. BUT AWAY. OKAY
IF I COULD JUMP INTO. IT MY
UNDERSTANDING HERE BASED ON THE
ANALYSIS AT THE FIVE EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS FOR THIS YEAR IS
TO ADDRESS. USER MAKE A LEGACY
SYSTEM CONTINUE WORKING BUT THE
LONG TERM GOAL IS TO FULLY
REPLACES LEGACY SYSTEMS. IN
WHICH CASE I ASSUME IT'S A MUCH
LARGER COSTS IS THAT A FAIR
ASSUMPTION. MANY ME TRY TO TAKE
THAT UNTIL WE'RE IN THE MIDDLE
OF MODERNISATIONS ARE TRYING TO
DO TWO DIFFERENT THINGS ONESELF.
ONE IS MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
LEGACY SYSTEMS THAT I SPOKE WITH
THE SILOS AS I REFERRED TO THEM.
YOU CAN'T COMMUNICATE AND WE CAN
DO OUR JOB ACROSS ASSISTANCE.
OVER THE NEXT FEW YEARS WE HAVE-
BUDGET FROM FROM YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I DOUBT THAT ARE
HELPING US MODERNIZE AS WE
MODERNIZE WE'RE GOING TO BE.
CONSOLIDATED SOME ASSISTANCE IN
THAT'S ALREADY COVERED IN A DISH
AND ADDITION OF BUDGET. SO
THAT'S NOT THE MODERN AGE ISN'T
GONNA SOLVE EVERY SILO BUT IT'S
GOING TO CONSOLIDATE A NUMBER OF
THEM. WHICH WILL SERVE OBVIATE
THE NEED FOR THIS FEDERATED.
FEDERATED STRATEGY. YOU KNOW.
GOING INTO THE FUTURE BUT IT
WE'RE STILL GETTING THE REST OF
IT HAVE SOME FEDERATED SILOS
THAT ARE GOING TO STILL BE.
ISOLATED UNITS THAT ARE NOT PART
OF OUR MAIN MODERNIZATION
STRATEGY WHICH IS VERY VERY
FOCUSED ON VEHICLE REGISTRATION.
DRIVER'S LICENSE IN AN
OCCUPATIONAL LICENSE BUT AS
YOU'RE PROBABLY AWARE DMV HAS
MANY OTHER FACETS OF THE
BUSINESS. THAT ARE NOT PART OF
THAT MAINLINE MODERNISATIONS ARE
STILL GONNA NEED THIS TECHNOLOGY
TO HELP US SCHEDULE OF THAT
BECAUSE- THE TEARS MAKING OF.
REYES I THINK THAT MAYBE GOT A
MISTER GORDON THANK YOU I THINK
YOU HAVE TO HAVE A COPY BUSINESS
BUT I THINK THAT THE GENERAL YOU HAVE BUDGET FOR
THE LARGER KIND OF MODERNIZATION
PROCESS THIS BUDGET IS TO
ADDRESS EGIN ACCOUNT OF THE
MAKING SURE THAT THE SILENT
LEGACY OPERATION CONTINUES TO.
WORK APPERLEY FOR THE TIME BEING
IS THAT CORRECT. YES NOT MAKE
SENSE TO ME. AND THE I'M SORRY
THE- THE BIGGER MODERNIZATION.
WHAT IS THE ESTIMATED TIME FRAME
FOR THAT. MONTEROSSO WE'VE
COMPLETED OUR FIRST PHASE OF OUR
FIRST RELEASE OF OUR FIRST PHASE
IT'S A IT'S A MULTI YEAR JOURNEY
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN THREE AND FOUR
YEARS YEAH YOU ARE ON THE TIME I
TIME I BUT WE ARE HALFWAY
THROUGH WITH OUR FIRST PHASE
RIGHT NOW. AFTER OCCUPATIONAL
LICENSING WHERE IN THE
CONTRACTING PHASE FOR A VEHICLE
REGISTRATION WHICH IS OUR
LARGEST UP THE CARAVAN AND THEY
WERE JUST STARTING NOW THE
BUILDING OF THE PAL DOCUMENTS WE
JUST TALK ABOUT FOR THE DRIVER'S
LICENSE. SO IT'S PROBABLY GONNA
BE THREE YEARS THREE TO FOUR
YEAR TIME HORIZON HOBBY EXACTLY
IN FRONT OF ME BY DEATH BUT AT
THAT POINT IN TIME WE WILL THEN
HAVE BE ABLE TO TURN OFF TO ME
VERY VERY LEGACY SYSTEM SOME
THAT WERE YOU ARCHITECT IN THE
FIFTIES AND SIXTIES AND YOU'RE
NOT GOING WHAT THEY'RE STILL
WORKING TODAY BUT OBVIOUSLY IT'S
A- GOOD FOR US. TO BE ABLE TO
RETIRE THE SYSTEM TO BE ON A
MODERATE PLATFORM TO NOT ONLY
EXTEND OUR SYSTEMS TO REACH
CALIFORNIANS IT ALSO REDUCED
RISK OF SOME OF THOSE LEGACY
SYSTEMS. OF FAILING TO START UP
IN THE MORNING. OKAY GOD IT.
ANYMORE COMMENTS QUESTIONS NONE
OKAY GREAT OKAY- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- MR GORDON AND MR SCOTT- WE
DONE WITH THAT ISSUE. AND WE'RE
NOW GOING TO MOVE ON TO PUBLIC
COMMENTS AND SOLAR DISCUSSION
ITEMS WELL WE'RE DONE WITH THEM
WE WANT THE PUBLIC COMMENT AND
THEN WE WILL TAKE UP VOTING ON
THE ON THE- I'D WAS FOR VOTING.
SO ANYONE WANTING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT REGARDING THE
ITEMS ON THE AGENDA TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBERS
877-226-8163 AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS SEVEN THREE SIX TWO EIGHT
THREE THREE. OF THEM. I'M GOING
TO ASK THAT EACH MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC OF PROVIDING COMMENT KEEP
YOUR REMARKS TWO WITHIN A MINUTE
AND WE WILL START WITH ANY
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK HERE
IN THE HEARING ROOM. PLEASE COME
RIGHT UP ON. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHARTER ALSO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CHRISLEY ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
OF COUNTIES- IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF ISSUE SEVENTEEN RELATED TO
THE TRANSPORTATION AND FREIGHT
INFRASTRUCTURE PACKAGE. REALLY
WANNA HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE THINGS
HERE THE BRIDGE FUNDING ITEM IS
SOMETHING THAT'S VERY NEAR AND
DEAR TO US WE HAVE OVER SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS OF CITY AND
COUNTY BRIDGE PROJECTS AND SOME
SPECIAL DISTRICTS. AROUND THE
STATE THAT NEED FUNDING WE'RE
GETTING ABOUT TWO POINT EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS FROM THE AYE AYE
J. THE FEDERAL INFRASTRUCTURE
BILL BUT THAT'S SPLIT BETWEEN
THE STATE AND LOCAL SO THIS ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND INVESTMENT FOR
THE HIGH COST LOCAL BRIDGES OF
WHICH WE HAVE ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION. WILL NOT ONLY HELP US
SPREAD THAT FEDERAL FUNDING FROM
THE FORMULA PROGRAM FURTHER
IT'LL ALSO PUT US IN A GREAT
POSITION TO COMPETE FOR THE NEW
COMPETITIVE FUNDING AT. LEVEL
I'M ALSO THE ONLY SUPPORTIVE OF
THE INVESTMENTS IN CLIMATE
CHANGE ADAPTATION FOR
TRANSPORTATION ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION AND HIGHWAY
SAFETY. THANK YOU FOR THAT.
THANK YOU WE SHOULD YOUR
COMMENTS. ANYONE ELSE IN THE
ROOM OKAY SEE NONE- MODERATOR.
IT WERE READY TO- TAKE ANYONE
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT. IF YOU WOULD
QUEUE UP. CERTAINLY A LEGION
GENTLEMAN HER COMMENTS PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TOUCH TONE PHONE ONE AND THEN
ZERO FOR COMPLIMENTS. AND THE
FIRST ONE IS FROM LINE FIFTY TWO
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
MAKAYLA RIGHT CORRECT AND I'M
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE FAMILY
TALE COUNTY TRANSIT DISTRICT.
SAMTRANS OPERATE FASTER
THROUGHOUT IN THE TAIL COUNTY
AND INTO PARTS OF SAN FRANCISCO
AND PALO ALTO OUR GOAL IS TO
SUPPLY PEOPLE WITH THE HIGHEST
QUALITY SAFE AND EFFICIENT
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM THAT
ENHANCES THE QUALITY OF LIFE BY
INCREASING ACCESS AND MOBILITY.
REDUCING CONGESTION IMPROVING
THE ENVIRONMENT AND PROMOTING
ECONOMIC VITALITY WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT A SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT
AND PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION. IT
PANDEMIC HIS HEAD ALL OF US AND
WE NEED THE FUNDS TO CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE HIGH QUALITY SERVICE TO
OUR CUSTOMERS. OVER 90% AT THE
ENTRANCE WRITERS ARE LOW INCOME
WITH 64% OF THOSE IDENTIFYING AS
EXTREMELY LOW INCOME NEARLY 80%
OF RESPONDENTS TO A RECENT
WRITER SURVEYS BUT THEY DO NOT
HAVE ACCESS TO A CAR. WE ARE
COMMITTED TO PROVIDING
SUSTAINABLE PUBLIC TRANSIT
SERVICES FOR WRITERS AND SAMMA
TAIL COUNTY WHILE ALSO HELPING
TO IMPROVE AIR QUALITY
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE BAY AREA.
WE'RE CONVERTING THAT THE
ENTRANCE VASTLY FROM DIESEL
21100% ZERO EMISSIONS BY TWENTY
FORTY AND INVESTING IN CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE. TO SUPPORT THIS
TRANSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH UP NEXT PLEASE.
CERTAINLY WE GO TO LINE NUMBER
SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MICHAEL CAMPBELL
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSIT ASSOCIATION I
JOIN YOU TODAY TO VOICE OUR
APPRECIATION TO YOU AND THE REST
OF THE FROM A SHORTAGE FOR
INTRODUCING A STRONG
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING PACKAGE.
SHE SEVENTEEN THAT'S WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION JANUARY PROPOSAL
FOURTEEN FROM A SHORTAGE OF NEW
INVESTMENT TRANSPORTATION COURT
PUBLIC TRANSIT AND RAIL WE THINK
THE SENATE MAJORITY FOR HEATING
POWER AND OUR MEMBER CALL. TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT IN
PUBLIC TRANSALPINA RATIONS
PROPOSAL LOOK FORWARD TO
REVIEWING THE ADDITIONAL DETAILS
OF THE SENATE MAJORITY PACKAGE
AS THEY ARE RELEASED I AND WE
WILL CONTINUE TO URGE THAT ONE A
PORTION OF NEW TRENDS IN REAL
INVESTMENT THE EXCEPT FOR THE
AGENCIES. TO DRAFT COST
INCREASES FOR FIFTEEN PROJECT-
POP INCREASES PARTIALLY BORNE
OUT BY THE INFLATIONARY
PRESSURES THAT MANY ARE PROJECTS
ARE EXPERIENCING TO THAT TRANSIT
AGENCIES BE DEEMED ELIGIBLE
ENTITIES FOR CLIMATE ADAPTATION
FUNDING AND THEN THREE THAT
FUNDING FOR GRADE SEPARATIONS
FLOW THROUGH THE PPP'S GRADE
SEPARATION PROGRAM. I KNOW AS
YOU A KNOWLEDGE THERE IS A
TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY
MAKE SIZEABLE INVESTMENT GIVEN
THE BIPARTISAN INFRASTRUCTURE
BILL THE FEDS HAVE JUST PASSED
BY AND WE SEE THAT THE STATE
INVESTMENT COULD BE A STRONG
LOCAL MATCH THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU PEASHOOTER.
COMMENTS NEXT PLEASE. WE HAVE A. SEVEN SEVEN. SEVEN SEVEN ARE
YOU I MEAN. HI APOLOGIES FOR
THAT- GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE MY
NAME'S JACOB FALKO AND THE
GOVERNMENT YOUR THE AFFAIRS
MANAGER AT CALTRAIN I'M HAPPY
CALTRAIN WE WANT TO THANK THE
SENATE FOR PUTTING THE
TRANSPORTATION PLAN FOR THE PAST
NINETEEN SEVENTEEN AND FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND SUPPORT OF PUBLIC
TRANSIT. CONFERENCE STRONGLY
SUPPORTS ADOPTION OF A RIVER
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
PACKAGES THIS YEAR I'M HERE
CALTRAIN WE'RE MOVING FORWARD ON
OUR ELECTRIC EDUCATION PROJECT
WHICH WILL CONVERT CONVERT 95%
OF OUR PEOPLE SLEEP HIGH.
PERFORMANCE ELECTRIC TRAINS.
WHICH WILL NOT ONLY HOW ACHIEVE
TRANSFERRED PAGEL CUT OFF PARK.
AMBITIOUS TARGETS FACT THE
FAMILY REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS. THIS FOR ME THAT IS
NOT RESOURCES THAT SHE
COMPLETION TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
AND WE'RE VERY HOPEFUL THAT
FUNDING FROM THE STATE
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
PACKAGE CAN HELP CLOSE THE GAP.
WHICH WILL BENEFIT BOTH THE
REGION AND STATE. WERE ALSO
SUPPORTIVE OF THE INCLUSION OF
OTHER IMPORTANT TRANSIT
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS
INCLUDING HIGH SPEED RAIL AND
GREAT BRITIAN. AND LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING TO WORK THE
LEGISLATURE AND ADMINISTRATION
TO FINALIZE IT. TRANSPORTATION
PACKAGE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU FOR. NEXT PLEASE. WE
HAVE LINE SEVENTY THREE. MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS TERAFLOPS ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
FEDERATION OF LABOR AND HERE TO
SPEAK ON ISSUE SEVENTEEN AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE SENATE
PROPOSAL TO INCLUDE LABOR
FIREMAN'S ON THE INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENTS IN THE BUDGET THAT
THEY PROPOSED- WITH THE GOAL OF
CREATING STABLE HIGH QUALITY
JOBS THAT ARE EQUITABLY
DISTRIBUTED THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. AND OTHER BUDGET INVEST
TENS OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
TRANSPORTATION AND CLIMATE
INFRASTRUCTURE WE REALLY NEED
ENFORCEABLE COMMITMENTS TO
ENSURE THAT PUBLIC FUNDING
CREATES AND RETAINS GOOD JOBS
AND MOVE STAY CLOSER TO A MORE
JUST AND EQUITABLE ECONOMY- WE
NEED TO CREATE GOOD JOBS FOR THE
WORKERS WHO NEED THE MOST IN THE
AREAS OF THE STATE THAT NEED
THOSE JOBS WITH MOST AND WE
REALLY THINK THIS PROPOSAL.
MOVES US CLOSER TO THAT GOAL SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND WE
SUPPORT THAT VERY STRONGLY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR CALLING
IN NEXT PLEASE. NINE FIFTY SIX.
THANK YOU CHAIR NUMBERS FALLING
HUNTER ON BEHALF OF SANTA CLARA
VALLEY TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY
OFFICE SPEAKING ON ISSUE
SEVENTEEN THE FIRST THANK THE
SENATE MAJORITY FOR THE
TRANSPORTATION PACKAGE DETAILS
ARE AND APPLAUDED SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT IN TRANSIT THE
PROPOSAL GOES A LONG WAY TO
MEETING OUR TRANSIT
TRANSPORTATION NEEDS FROM STATE.
ALSO THRILLED TO SEE- THAT
INCLUDES DOLLARS FOR GREAT THAT.
I WE HAVE STATED- EARLIER AND OF
ENGINE BY A RAW. WE DO THINK
IT'S SPECIFICALLY. PROJECTS THAT
REQUIRE ADDITIONAL STATE FUNDING
TO SIX OR MAINTAIN OUR FEDERAL
INVESTMENTS. THIS PRIORITIZATION
WOULD ENSURE THAT PROJECTS SUCH
AS OUR PER FACILITY BALLY. PLACE
TO- AND CALTRAIN
ELECTRIFICATION- CAN COMPLETE
THEIR SPENDING PLANS ON SECURING
MAINTAIN. CRITICAL INSIGNIFICANT
SEVERAL SUPPORT. WE BELIEVE
THERE IS NEED FOR TRADE BILL
LIKE TO A JUST STOP BY MY- TO A
LOT OF NUMBER. DEPRIVE AND FOR
OTHER NEEDED FIXES SHORTENED. BE
THE MECHANISM FOR FIVE I CAN
PROVIDE A INVESTMENT IN TRAINS.
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONTINUED
EFFORTS ON AND ALSO THINK FOR
THE QUICK HEAVY IN HIS TEAM THE
TIRELESS EFFORTS. SO FAR AND
ALSO TO DISTRACT HER FOR HIS
CONTINUED. FOCUSING IMPORTANT-
ON TRANSFER TRANSIT. THANK YOU.
ALL THANK YOU APPRECIATE MUCH
YOU CALL IN PLEASE. LINE SIXTY
SIX. CORRECT THAT THEIR NUMBERS
ON HIM TO BE ON BEHALF OF U. A.
W. WESTERN STATES REPRESENTING
OVER ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND ACTIVE
AND RETIRED UAW MEMBERS ARE
CALLING INSTRUCT THE COURT FOR
ITEM SEVENTEEN AND IN PARTICULAR
ATTACHING ENFORCEABLE LABOR
STANDARDS TO OUR TRANSPORTATION
CLIMATE AND WORKFORCE INVESTMENT
WE MUST PRIORITIZE THE CREATION
OF HIGH QUALITY JOBS INCLUDING
IN THE MANUFACTURING SECTOR TO
REBUILD OUR COMMUNITIES EXPAND
JOB OPPORTUNITIES. AND YOUR
FAMILY A PATH OUT OF POVERTY BY
PROVIDING THEM WITH. GOOD
QUALITY UNION JOBS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT PLEASE. LINE SIXTY FOUR. A
GOOD AFTERNOON STEVEN JONES
EXTERNAL AFFAIRS REPRESENTATIVE
FROM TH ALAMEDA CONTRA COSTA
TRANSIT DISTRICT OR EASY TRANSIT
IN OAKLAND COMMENTING ON ISSUE
NUMBER SEVENTEEN WE THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR WORK AND TO
SUPPORT ITS PROPOSED TWENTY
BILLION DOLLAR TRANSPORTATION
PACKAGE AND WE ALSO APPRECIATE
THE EFFORT TO MORE FAIRLY
ALLOCATE FUNDS AMONG THE STATES
TRANSIT PROVIDERS TWENTY BILLION
DOLLARS FOR TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE IS URGENTLY
NEEDED WILL COST FIFTY TRANSIT
MORE THAN ONE BILLION DOLLARS.
MEET THE STATE MANDATE REQUIRING
TRANSIT AGENCIES OPERATE 1100%
ZERO EMISSION FLEET BY TWENTY
FOR AN ADDITIONAL ONE POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS IS NEEDED TO
IMPROVE TRANSIT CORRIDORS AND
UPGRADE OUR AGING FACILITY. BUT
FOR TRANSIT OPERATE IS JUST
DOESN'T. TREND REVENUES ARE DOWN
COSTS CONTINUE TO INCREASE
EIGHTY TRANSIT IS FACING A ONE
HUNDRED AND ELEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS FISCAL CLIFF. AND OTHER
OPERATORS A SIMILAR DEFICIT. WE
SUPPORT THE COMMITTEES TWENTY
BILLION DOLLAR PROPOSAL AND URGE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR TRANSIT
OPERATIONS. SO WE CAN CONTINUE
TO PROVIDE OUR CENTRAL SERVICE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
YOUR COMMENTS ARE VERY IMPORTANT
NEXT PLEASE. NINE EIGHTY. GOOD
AFTERNOON. VERY FIVE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THIS IS MARK WHAT I'M
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF
TRANSPORTATION CALIFORNIA
COALITION- CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY
AND ALLIED LABOR AND THANK YOU
FOR EVERY OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT
ON ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN. WHEN
THE GOVERNOR USED HIS ARE MAY
READ HIS A REGIONAL JET- JANUARY
BUDGET WE WERE VERY PLEASED WITH
THE- ATTENTION TAKING
TRANSPORTATION YET AGAIN- THE
REASON MARK PLEASE HADN'T SEEN
THE RELEASE OF THE SENATE
MAJORITY TWENTY. BILLION DOLLAR
PACKAGE ARE WE FOR TICKET
SUPPORT- AND ARE GRATEFUL FOR
INCLUSION OF AUGMENTATION
THROUGH SEVERAL BECOME. GRANT
PROGRAMS FROM S. B. ONE HI
INCLUDING THE TWO BILLION DOLLAR
PROPOSAL FOR ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THE FINDINGS HAVE
BEEN THEM SENATE MAJORITY
PACKAGE. HARPER CLIMATE
ADAPTATION PROGRAMS AND FUNDING
OVER A MULTI YEAR PERIOD. AND
TOGETHER WITH C. SECTION OTHERS-
WE HAVE. BEEN WORKING DILIGENTLY
TO SEEK FUNDING FOR HIGH COST
BRIDGES WHICH WE SEE. IN IN YOUR
PRO. FINALLY WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH BOTH. IN THIS GRADE
IN BOTH HOUSES- AS YOU MAY
REVIVE COMES TO. AND WE WANT TO
DELIVER TOGETHER A VERY ROBUST
TRANSPORTATION INVESTMENT DEAL
HAD LAST NOT LEAST WE WANT TO
THANK YOU. HI JAMES HACKER WE'RE
ALWAYS BEING AVAILABLE AND
GIVING US GOOD GUIDANCE FROM THE
PROCESS OKAY VERY MUCH. OH BOY
YEAH A LOT OF ATTENTION MR
HACKER. WELL DESERVED. OKAY
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. A LINE.
SEVENTY SIX. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
MY NAME IS LAURA LANE AND I'M
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS SENSATIONAL FOR THE
FORTY OR POP UP WHICH REPRESENTS
CALIFORNIA'S ELEVEN PUBLIC
FORCE. STRONG SUPPORT OF ISSUE
SEVENTEEN THE ONE POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS IN THE GENERAL
FUND SPENDING PROPOSED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET BEFORE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THE GENERAL FUND
INVESTMENT BOERNER HORVATH
PERSPECTIVE YOU CAN JUST CHECK
ON THE DRESSING CRITICAL NEED-
OR- BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND AND
TWENTY TWENTY CONTAINERIZED
CARGO VOLUMES IN CALIFORNIA GREW
BY EIGHTY PERCENT. GROWTH OKAY
REPUBLICATION FROM THE
COLLECTION A CALIFORNIA COURT
PROACTIVELY THINKING FACTOR LEVY
THANK YOU CHANGE CONGESTION.
HOWEVER THE NEED FOR CURRENT
TODAY. AND IN THE FUTURE.
ADDITIONAL METHOD IS NEEDED.
EVEN BACK HOME OF OUR CORE TO
RESPOND TO GROWING TRADE ABOUT
ABOUT IN OUR- AND INCREASE THE
CAPACITY TO BECAUSE BISHOP LANE. IN CAPITAL PART OF A THE
PLANET PACKAGE WHICH IS EIGHT
BILLION PRIORITY. ISSUE ON
LATEST THREE POINT BILLION FOR
GROUP. ON BEHALF OF HAPPEN THANK
YOU FOR THE- TO OUR SUPPORTER
THE BUDGET. AND WE LOOK FOR TO
CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS OF THE
THOUGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. LEVINE SEVENTY. IT
WILL AIRBORNE MAY BE ON THE-
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS EDGAR
MARTINEZ AND I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF EARTHJUSTICE. AND
COMMENTING REGARDING ITEM NUMBER
SEVENTEEN LIKE THE EXPRESS OUR
CORPORATE CAFFEINE AFFORDABLE
LABOR STANDARDS START
TRANSPORTATION CLIMB IN
WORKFORCE INVESTMENT. PROJECTED
PARTICIPATE THEN L. A. COUNTY
ELECTRIC TRUCK BUT POLLUTION AND
DETECT MAPPERS ARE PORTANTINO
MAKE SURE THAT AS WE CLEAN UP
OUR TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM OR
CREATING GOOD HIGH QUALITY JOBS-
I WOULD LIKE TO SUPPORT THE
CONTINUED WORK TO MAKE SURE THAT
OUR PUBLIC DOLLARS ARE GETTING
TO WORK CLEAN UP BUT OFF THE
CREATING GOOD JOBS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH R. D. THIS.
NEXT PLEASE. A LOT. SEVEN TWO.
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR- MELANIE PROVIDE ON BEHALF
OF JOHNSON'S AMERICA EXPECTING
STRONG SUPPORT FOR ITEM NUMBER
SEVENTEEN I IN PARTICULAR
ATTACHING IMPORTANCE BOWLING FOR
A STANDARD TRY TRANSPORTATION.
FROM WORKFORCE INVESTMENT. ON
FIFTY WE HAVE HAD IMPORTANT. AT
HOME TO HELP LEVERAGE THE OVER
TWENTY BILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT
IN TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
TO CREATE GREAT HIGH QUALITY
CLEAN SHOP AND I'D BE. ON PUBLIC
PROCUREMENT IS A CRITICAL STEP
IN ENSURING THAT ACTUALLY
IMPACTING THE CLEAN ENERGY
FUTURE WILL CREATE JOBS
ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE WHO LEFT
SHORTLY THE NIGHT ACCESS TO
QUALITY AND POINT. THEM YEAH.
AND THE THING YOU FOR YOUR THAT
YOU DO ALL OVER THE COUNTRY NEXT
PLEASE. WINDS SIXTY NINE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ARE BACK ALONG WITH THE
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION IN THE SAN FRANCISCO
BAY AREA SPEAKING TODAY ON ITEM
SEVENTEEN WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE SENATE MAJORITY PROPOSAL TO
EXPAND UPON THE GOVERNOR'S
TRANSPORTATION PACKAGE WITH A
MULTI YEAR TWENTY BILLION DOLLAR
PROPOSAL WHAT HIGH SPEED RAIL
ISN'T ON TODAY'S AGENDA WE DO
WANT TO REITERATE OUR SUPPORT
FOR THE ADMINISTRATION'S FOUR
POINT TWO. MILLION DOLLAR
REQUEST. THANK SEGMENT. IN THE
SENATE PACKAGE WE ESPECIALLY
SUPPORT THE FOCUSED ON PUBLIC
TRANSIT. A ROBUST FUNDING LEVEL
SUFFICIENT TO CLOSE FUNDING
GAPS. IN MAJOR TRANSIT TRANSIT
PROJECTS UNDERWAY STATEWIDE. IN
THE BAY AREA WE'VE IDENTIFIED
OVER TEN BILLION DOLLARS IN NEAR
TERM PROJECTS FUNDING NEEDS FOR
MARK LARGE OPERATORS A LOT. OF
THIS IS FOR PROJECTS THAT THE
FEDERAL TRANSIT ADMINISTRATION
HAS CONDITIONALLY AGREED TO
SUPPORT. THE REGIONAL MATCHING
FUNDS ARE REQUIRED TO GUARANTEE
THAT COMMITMENT AND LEVERAGE
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN FEDERAL
MATCHING FUNDS. WE ALSO STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE REQUEST FOR
INCREASED FUNDING FOR GRADE
SEPARATIONS WHICH WILL ALSO HELP
LEVERAGES FEDERAL FUNDS IN THIS
CATEGORY. AND WHAT. IN THAT.
TRANSPORTATION CRIME AT AND
RICHARD- I ALSO LIKE TO THANK
CENTER CORTES THE AND COMMITTEE
STAFF TEAM TUCKER FOR THEIR
PERFORMANCE PACKAGE AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE OF THE NEXT FIVE WEEKS
TO FINALISE TRANSPORTATION
PACKAGE AND NEXT YEAR'S BUDGET
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
AS LONG- OKAY. NEXT PLEASE. OF
MINE SEVENTY NINE. THE
GOVERNMENT ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN COUNCIL OF ENGINEERING
COMPANIES I'M SPEAKING TODAY ON
ISSUE SEVENTEEN JUST WANNA THE
SENATE FOR YOUR EFFORTS TO BUILD
UPON THE GOVERNOR'S- JANUARY
BUDGET PROPOSAL- ESPECIALLY PER
SHOOT THE INCREASE FUNDING
TOWARD SB ONE PROGRAMS
ESPECIALLY THE YOUTH PROGRAM AND
WANTED TO ACT WITH SENATOR
NEWMAN SCOTT COMMENTS ABOUT
MAKING THIS THING LIST OF
APPLICANTS ABOUT PROGRAM AND NOT
REQUIRING A NEW APPLICATION
PROCESS THAT. CAN SELF I THOUGHT
ABOUT THAT AND ABOUT- THE
INVESTMENT HIGH COSTS WHICH IS
AND ARE REALLY LOOKING FORWARD
TO OTHER AREAS INVESTMENT IN
TRANSPORTATION INCOME
INFRASTRUCTURE INCLUDING MAX
ITSELF THEY COULD NOT I'M SORRY. COULD YOU GIVE ME YOUR NAME
AGAIN. ONE THING WOULD GIVE ME
COUNCIL JAMAICA. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT LINE. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE THIS IS KIANA
VALENTINE ON BEHALF OF UNITED
CONTRACTORS. MAKING I'M ISSUES
SEVENTEEN FOR FIGHT TO ALIGN MY
COMMENTS WITH OF MARC WATTS
REPRESENTING TRANSPORTATION
CALIFORNIA AN ORGANIZATION THAT
UNITED CONTRACTORS IS A PART OF.
THAT SO- ALONG WITH THAT WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE AND GREATLY
APPRECIATE THAT SENATE-
MAJORITIES INVESTMENT TWENTY
BILLION DOLLARS VER FOUR YEARS
INTO A ROBUST MULTI MODAL
TRANSPORTATION PACKAGE- I
THOUGHT TEN OTHERS HAVE SPOKE TO
THE DIFFERENT INVESTMENTS THAT
WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF. I WOULD
TALK A LITTLE BIT WITH MY MINUTE
THAT. THE NEW THE DAVID. THAT
THE STATE OF. WILL RECEIVE BY
ITS INVESTMENT ONE TIME
INVESTMENT IN INFRASTRUCTURE A
RECENT REPORT- CONCLUDED THAT
FOR EVERY ONE DOLLAR INVESTED IN
INFRASTRUCTURE THERE IS FOUR
DOLLARS AND THIRTY CENTS AND
ECONOMIC ACTIVITY AT THAT IS
RETURNED AND SO IF YOU PULL BACK
THROUGH THE TWENTY MILLION
DOLLAR PACKAGE YOU CAN EXPECT TO
RECEIVE. EIGHTY SIX BILLION
DOLLARS IN ECONOMIC ACTIVITY FOR
THE INVESTMENT AFTER MORALLY FOR
EVERYONE BILLION DOLLAR INVESTED
IN IT CREATE FIFTEEN THOUSAND
JOBS. SO A TWENTY BILLION DOLLAR
FOR YOUR PACKAGE I CAN BE
EXPECTED TO ACHIEVE THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND LIVING WAGE-
JOBS THROUGHOUT THE ECONOMY IN
CALIFORNIA AND SO FOR ALL OF
THOSE REASONS WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. AND DEFEND IT PACKAGE
AND LOOK FORWARD TO- THE LAST
FEW WEEKS OF NEGOTIATIONS TO
FINALIZE THE BUDGET THANK YOU SO
MUCH GREAT THANK YOU MS
VALENTINE THE- VALUABLE IN. OF
NEXT LEASE. WE HAVE LINE. EIGHTY
FIVE. A GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
BACK WILL YOU ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA GREEN NEW DEAL
COALITION I'M CALLING IN SICK
RESTAURANT SUPPORT FOR ITEM
NUMBER SEVENTEEN AND
SPECIFICALLY ATTACHING
ENFORCEABLE LABOR STANDARDS YOU
ARE TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE CRIME AND
WORKFORCE INVESTMENT. AND THAT
MANY HAVE OUTLINED FOR ME THIS
IS A REALLY UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY
TO USE THE OVER TWENTY BILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT IN
TRANSPORTATION AND
INFRASTRUCTURE TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE CREATING HIGH QUALITY-
GOOD CLEAN JOBS IN OUR STATE.
PUBLIC PROCUREMENT IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT TOOL THAT THE STATE
HAS TO BUILD A HIGH ROAD ECONOMY
TO REALLY ENSURE THAT THE STATE
INVESTMENT AND A CLEAN ENERGY
FUTURE ARE ALSO CREATING GOOD
JOB ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE WHO
HAVE BEEN HISTORICALLY DENIED
ACCESS TO QUALITY EMPLOYMENT I
REALLY WANT TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
WE'RE NOT USING THE FUNDS THAT
THE FOR A LOW RED. BRAKE BUTTON
UP APPROACH I'VE BEEN THE FAT.
IN THE COURT OF THE LATE
STANDARDS THE COULD HERE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. YOUR
COMMENTS NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU
AT THIS TIME THEY'RE NOT FOR THE
LINES IN Q. OKAY I WAS. I WAS
LIKE YOU KNOW LOS COMMENTS. IT
WILL BE A REALLY MR HACKER WELL
DONE YOU YOU'RE GETTING ALL THE
- ALL THE GOOD GOOD ACCOLADES
THAT YOU DESERVE GOOD FOR YOU
OKAY FROM THE HOUSEHOLD NAME.
THE MILLIONS WATCHING AT HOME.
GOOD EVENING OR ABOUT THE- WELL
BUT COLLEAGUES YOU'VE GOTTEN
YOUR SHARE COMMENTS TWO BEDS
RIGHT. OKAY COMMITTEE HEARING
SHOULD BE THE G. YES YEAH- LET'S
SEE I THINK WE'VE HEARD FROM ALL
THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC ANY
FURTHER COMMENTS COLLEAGUES A
HEARING ON WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON
NOW TO THE VOTE WEEK UNDER.
PANICKED OF WE HAVE SEVERAL
MOTIONS. OKAY WITH. WE WILL MOVE
ON TO FIVE MOTIONS TAKING UP THE
VARIOUS PHAM ISSUES THAT NEED A
VOTE TODAY. SO AND THEN AGAIN I
COULD MILLION MEMBERS MOTION
MOTION WANTED TO ADOPT STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR ISSUES. ONE
TWO SIX SEVEN AND FOURTEEN. OKAY
THE MOVE MOTION OF THE MADE TO
HEAR. WE NEED A SECOND NO OKAY
GOOD OKAY OF THE. EVERYBODY
CLEAR ON THAT ONE OKAY MR HACKER
. YOUR BROWSER I CORTESE GROVE
NEWMAN ALL RIGHT. OKAY MOTION
NUMBER TWO NUMBER TWO OUR MOTION
I'D LIKE TO MAKE THE MOST NEW
JOBS STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS ON
ISSUES. 345-910-1112 THIRTEEN
FIFTEEN AND SIXTEEN. THE NAY
DIRECTOR YOUR BROWSER BY CORTESE
WROTE HI NEWMAN ALL RIGHT. K.
FOUR ZERO NEXT MOTION YES MA'AM
SURE JUDGE BY THE MOTIONS TO
ADOPT STAFF RECOMMENDATION ON
THIS DEFINITION ISSUE NUMBER
EIGHT. MISTER YOUR BROWSER I
CORTESE GROVE. NEWMAN HI. THREE
ZERO. JUST NEWMAN THE MOTION IS
TO APPROVE APPROVE IS BUDGETED-
ISSUE NUMBER NINETEEN. MR HACKER
. THE RAZA HI CORTESE GROVE
NEWMAN ALL RIGHT. THE THREE ONE
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH AT LAST
. I'D LIKE TO MOVE A APPROVED
HIS BUDGET ON ISSUE NUMBER
TWENTY ONE. OKAY POSTED BEEN
MADE MISTER HECKER RAZA CORTESE
WROTE NEWMAN RIGHT. WE HAVE FOUR
ZERO OKAY THE POPULAR PEOPLE IN
THE- OKAY- GOT ALL THAT THE ONLY
OF THE MOVE. AND I THINK THAT'S
IT NO MORE MOTIONS. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATE IN
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY WAS A
VERY IMPORTANT DAY TAKING UP OUR
OUR- IN PARTICULAR BUDGET
TRANSPORTATION- THE PROPOSAL IF
YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY
TODAY PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE YOUR COMMON SENSE AND
SUGGESTIONS HAVE BEEN AND ARE
VERY IMPORTANT TO US WE WANT
INCLUDED TESTIMONY INDIVIDUAL
HEARING RECORDS THANK YOU
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION WE HAVE CONCLUDED
THE AGENDA FOR TODAY'S HEARING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.